madame la ministre un grand merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je le
disais ça fait en aparté en quatre mois
c'est la deuxième fois que vous venez
merci d'avoir honoré ces deux
invitations
votre ministère est un beau ministère
votre portefeuille est un portefeuille
diversifié et tendu puisque vous êtes
chargé de la protection et de la
valorisation de la nature et de la
biodiversité ainsi que de l'économie
circulaire autant dire que de nombreuses
échéances se présentent à vous et
notamment une échéance très importante
qui est la COP15 la COP biodiversité ou
notre commission se rendra courante du
mois de décembre pour humblement
rappeler l'ambition de la France sur ces
sujets sur les négociations madame les
ministres pouvez-vous nous rappeler
l'ambition que vous portez puisque il me
semble qu'avec le Costa Rica la France
souhaite avoir une stratégie très
ambitieuse en matière de protection de
la biodiversité le deuxième point c'est
le sujet de l'eau il y a quelques jours
quelques semaines où vous étiez à
Marseille avec Christophe Béchu pour
lancer le premier chantier de l'eau sur
un sujet très important qui fait qu'au à
ce que nous avons notamment vécu cet été
avec des épisodes de sécheresse
pouvez-vous nous rappeler des grandes
orientations de ce chantier de l'eau
sans doute aussi le calendrier que vous
souhaitez porter le troisième point il
s'agit d'aborder avec vous l'économie
circulaire vous avez vous êtes beaucoup
vous avez beaucoup de vrai en tant que
parlementaire avec d'autres collègues
d'ailleurs sur la loi AGEC pouvez-vous
nous rappeler l'ambition que vous
souhaitez porter dans le cadre de votre
ministère et sans doute engager ce que
j'appelle moi le service après-vente
dernier point madame la ministre nous
avons nous serons amenés à discuter d'un
budget d'un budget qui me semble
ambitieux puisque en augmentation sur
ces sujets de lutte contre
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
protection de la biodiversité vous
pouvez vous nous rappeler les grandes
priorités de ce budget pour
2023 voilà madame la ministre je vous
laisse une dizaine de minutes et puis
vous le savez des députés c'est une
bonne chose ont beaucoup de questions à
vous poser merci beaucoup madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés merci pour cette
sonde invitation j'espère que je ne
serai pas trop bavarde et que je
respecterai les 10 minutes mais j'ai
quand même pas mal de choses à vous dire
parce qu'en effet mon portefeuille est
en effet assez large et donc je merci de
me donner ce temps nécessaire donc vous
dire déjà que évidemment l'été que nous
venons de traverser entre pèlerinidaux
pénurie d'eau pardon et incendie a été
une nouvelle illustration de l'urgence
écologique à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés et vous le savez mon
département de la Gironde a été
fortement touché par les incendies le
changement climatique a désormais un
impact extrêmement concret sur tous les
pans de notre vie quotidienne et que
plus personne je crois aujourd'hui ne
peut ne peut nier mais l'urgence elle
est également celle de la préservation
de la nature en 50 ans la situation de
nos espaces naturels de nos océans comme
de la faune mondiale est devenue
extrêmement alarmante
perte de 35% des lacs des rivières des
marais disparition de 66% des mammifères
perte de 80% des poissons d'eau douce un
million d'espèces sont aujourd'hui
menacées ce qui est inédit dans notre
histoire
le portefeuille qui m'a été confié à
cette vocation mettre la préservation de
la biodiversité au même niveau que le
climat cette extinction silencieuse qui
se déroule sous nos yeux doit être
combattue avec la plus grande force elle
constitue avec la lutte contre le
changement climatique une priorité
absolue du mandat du Président de la
République qui a nommé pour la première
fois une première ministre en charge de
la planification écologique c'est
historique et ce pilotage depuis
Matignon doit permettre d'impliquer
davantage des ministères dans cette
transition ce pilotage s'appuie sur des
moyens nouveaux et conséquents comme
vous le savez la première ministre a
annoncé un fond d'accélération de la
transition écologique dans les
territoires d'abord d'un milliard 500
millions d'euros plus de 2 milliards
d'euros dont au minimum 150 millions
d'euros pour la biodiversité il s'agit
bien de crédit nouveau tout s'orienter
vers l'adaptation de nos territoires aux
enjeux du changement climatique et de la
lutte contre l'érosion de la
biodiversité
le budget que je viens vous présenter
aujourd'hui et donc bien un budget de
cohérence entre l'ambition que nous
portons et les moyens que nous nous
donnons pour 2023 la préservation de la
biodiversité et la prévention des
risques bénéficieront de 3,6 milliards
d'euros je vais revenir sur le détail
les crédits sont stabilisés ou augmentés
les opérateurs sont renforcés et la fin
du plan de relance est compensé en
grande partie par la mise en place du
fond d'accélération de la transition
écologique dans les territoires la
troisième stratégie nationale
biodiversité qui est en cours
d'achèvement doit être la référence
cadre pour la mobilisation de nos
énergies et la mise en cohérence des
actions que nous menons et des moyens
que nous mettons en œuvre au niveau
national comme local comme je vous le
disais 150 millions d'euros lui seront
spécifiquement dédiés dans le 4 dans le
cadre pardon du fond d'accélération de
la transition écologique et leur
répartition se fera de la manière
suivante
50 millions d'euros seront dédiés à la
mise en oeuvre de la stratégie nationale
pour les aires protégées 25 millions
d'euros pour la protection des espèces
dont 15 millions d'euros pour des
mesures favorables aux insectes
pollinisateurs comme la plantation de
haie hors secteur agricole et 10
millions d'euros pour la conservation et
la d'espèces menacées dans le cadre de
plan nationaux d'action et donc ça
viendra en complément des 5 millions
d'euros dédiés du budget biodiversité du
PLF 2023
on compte également 20 millions d'euros
qui seront fléchés vers la lutte contre
les espèces exotiques envahissantes
c'est une accélération importante par
rapport aux trois millions d'euros
déployés l'année passée
20 millions d'euros iront vers la
dépollution dont la lutte contre les
plastiques avec des expérimentations de
récupération des macros déchets et des
actions de retrait des pavs abandonnés
dans les aires protégées et le fond
consacrera les 35 millions d'euros
restants à la résorption des principaux
obstacles continuité écologiques il
financeront également la
démultiplication des mouillages
écologiques de moindre impact sur les
fonds marins afin de protéger et de
restaurer les herbiers
le premier objectif de mon portefeuille
est donc bien la protection des espaces
naturels et des habitats c'est ce que je
porte avec la stratégie nationale Air
protégée qui a été inscrite dans la loi
climat et résilience elle a fixé deux
cibles majeures et vous les connaissez
déjà très bien protégez d'abord 30% de
notre territoire dont un tiers en
protection forte ces cibles concernent
l'Hexagone comme l'autre mère la terre
comme la mer nous cherchons évidemment
une répartition équilibrée entre ces
différents espaces avec comme priorité
de protéger ceux qui sont les plus
exceptionnels
aujourd'hui si l'objectif de protection
est atteint il reste encore du chemin à
parcourir en matière de protection forte
de nouveaux projets sont en cours de
réflexion localement et nous n'équartons
pas la possibilité d'un onzième parc
national sur les zones humides
sur cette question de la protection je
travaille aussi à l'aboutissement du
transfert aux régions des sites Natura
2000 décider par la loi 3DS le dialogue
se poursuit avec région de France
cette ambition de protection nous
l'apportons également à l'international
monsieur le Président la prochaine COP15
qui aura lieu en décembre à Montréal et
à ce titre décisive elle doit permettre
d'acter la protection de 30% des espaces
de notre planète en 2030 la France
s'engage en ce sens pour y parvenir la
protection de résolution que vous
préparez actuellement et
particulièrement importante pour montrer
que la position ambitieuse de la France
à l'international est soutenu par vous
donc par ces parlementaires
aussi la protection des espaces et des
habitats doit nous permettre de mieux
appréhender la seconde priorité qui est
la protection du vivant
les plans nationaux d'action constitue
un autre outil majeur qui vient en
complément du régime de protection
légale des espèces cette plante
nationaux de préservation d'espace dans
l'Hexagone comme en outre-mer ont été
lancés hier dans ce domaine la lutte
contre les captures accidentelles de
dauphins dans le golf de Gascogne est
aussi une priorité la France doit porter
une position ambitieuse qui permet de
garantir la préservation de cette espèce
protégée alors des mesures techniques
ont déjà été envisagées pour améliorer
nos connaissances et pour prévenir ses
captures nous allons accompagner la
profession avec une expérimentation à
grande échelle de ces mesures
l'équipement des bateaux par des caméras
bénéficiera d'un fonds de 4 millions
d'euros pour venir soutenir les pêcheurs
mais moi je vous le dis aujourd'hui les
fermetures spatio-temporelles ne sont
pas un tabou si elle s'avère la seule
solution efficace pour autant que
l'accompagnement des acteurs économiques
soient adaptés
l'eau est le troisième pan de cette
lutte pour la préservation de la
biodiversité cette année la France a
traversé une période de sécheresse
intense et prolongée et en application
des guides sécheresses et des arrêtés
cadres séches des restrictions ont été
prises sur l'ensemble des départements
des départements métropolitain
c'est pour répondre à ces tensions sur
l'eau que nous avons lancé vous l'avez
précisé monsieur le Président avec
Christophe Béchu et Agnès firmalobodo un
grand chantier sur l'Eau à Marseille le
29 septembre dernier nous n'aurons pas
d'autres choix de concilier les
différentes temporalités d'un côté
répondre à l'urgence de la situation
pour être mieux outillés dès l'été
prochain et de l'autre se projeter dans
le futur en nous appuyant sur les
projections scientifiques pour planifier
nos usages de l'eau à horizon 2050
principal financeur de la biodiversité
en France les agences de l'eau qui
bénéficient d'un plafond annuel de
recettes pour des redevances qui est
fixé à 2,2 milliards d'euros depuis la
loi de finances 2021 ce plafond est
maintenu tout comme leur plafond dans
leur plafond d'emploi pour 2023
souligne par ailleurs que les agences de
l'eau ont pu déployer cet été un plan de
résilience de 100 millions d'euros cela
a permis par un relèvement de leur
plafond de dépenses il s'agissait d'une
réponse très direct à la sécheresse que
nous avons connue ce plan de résilience
a notamment permis de soutenir les
collectivités territoriales et
d'accompagner les filières agricoles
enfin je partage l'enjeu de la
protection et d'une utilisation durable
de nos forêts avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture les forêts et les produits
bois sont au coeur de nos politiques de
transition écologique elles sont à la
fois une solution et des victimes du
changement climatique qui s'accélèrent
nous devons les rendre plus résilientes
au changement climatique alors qu'elle
concentre 80% de la biodiversité
terrestre dans le prolongement des
assises France 2030 à vocation à prendre
la suite de France relance dès 2023 200
millions d'euros seront consacrés à
l'adaptation des forêts au changement
climatique
s'agissant du renouvellement forestier
il est envisagé un financement pérenne
de 100 à 150 millions d'euros par an
mobilisant les outils de la finance
carbone
plus globalement la première ministre a
annoncée que la forêt serait un des
premiers secteurs concernés par la
planification écologique et dans cette
perspective je souhaite que les acquis
des Assises de la forêt servent de socle
pour prolonger et amplifier les actions
les moyens du ministère sont concentrés
sur le programme central autrement
intitulé paysage haut et biodiversité
que vous aurez à voter prochainement
dans le cadre de l'examen de la deuxième
partie du PLF il se concentre en effet
essentiellement sur la protection et la
reconquête des espaces naturels sur la
préservation des espèces et également
sur l'eau il connaît une nouvelle
augmentation de 30,4 millions d'euros
par rapport à 2022 et va atteindre donc
274 millions d'euros en 2023 il s'agit
de sa troisième année de hausse et cette
hausse tendancielle devrait se
poursuivre en 2024 et en 2025
pour 2023 seulement plusieurs
augmentations des montres à nouveau
notre engagement en matière de
préservation de la nature deux d'entre
elles concernent des opérateurs des
opérateurs auxquels je sais les députés
extrêmement attachés et sur lesquels
j'ai été régulièrement sollicité d'abord
l'Office français de la biodiversité qui
est sous la tutelle du ministère de la
transition écologique a pour objectif
général vous le savez la surveillance la
présence la préservation la gestion et
la restauration de la biodiversité ainsi
que la gestion équilibrée durable de
l'eau il est une structure essentielle
de notre politique de préservation de la
nature est nécessite à ce titre que ces
moyens soit en accord avec ses missions
en 2023 la subvention pour charge de
service public de l'ofb sera en hausse
de 25 millions d'euros un format
constant elle atteindra donc
78,8 millions d'euros et s'ajoutera à la
contribution de près de 383 millions
d'euros des agences de l'eau pour 2023
vous voyez je vous donne des chiffres
très complets second opérateur
particulièrement important pour les
parlementaires c'est l'Office National
des Forêts principalement sous tutelle
du ministère de l'agriculture mais qui
bénéficiera d'une augmentation pour ces
missions d'intérêt général de 2,5
millions d'euros par le programme 113
surtout je tiens à souligner ici qu'il
s'agit d'une hausse tendancielle
puisqu'en 2020 jusqu'en 2025
l'enveloppe pour les services d'intérêt
général aura augmenté de 5 millions
d'euros par rapport à 2022
le deuxième pan de mon portefeuille
c'est celui de l'économie circulaire
c'est la question de la gestion de nos
déchets en France nous devons
accompagner la transition d'une société
qui a trop produit trop consommé et trop
jeté nous devons tendre vers une société
de la réparation du réemploi et du
recyclage pour économiser nos ressources
et décarboner notre consommation
aujourd'hui les financements de
l'économie circulaire sont supportés
d'une part par les filières à
responsabilité élargi des producteurs
autrement appelé REP et d'autre part par
l'ADEME qui est l'opérateur de l'État
dans ce domaine
l'ADEME bénéficiera de crédit du
programme 180 pour le fond économie
circulaire qui est revalorisé à 220
millions d'euros pour 2023
le fond d'accélération de la transition
écologique dans les territoires pourra
également accompagner les collectivités
qui déploieront la collecte et la
valorisation des biodéchets enfin le
recyclage et la recherche des
alternatives aux produits plastiques à
usage unique seront soutenus par le
programme France 2030
ces moyens financiers doivent répondre à
un objectif clair
état collectivité producteurs et
consommateurs doivent réduire les
quantités de déchets mis en décharge et
développer le recyclage particulièrement
des plastiques ainsi que la valorisation
des biodéchets pour parvenir à cet
objectif d'une meilleure gestion de nos
déchets une trajectoire de hausse de la
taxe générale sur les activités
polluantes sur l'enfouissement des
déchets a été programmé entre 2018 et
2025 elle doit donner de la visibilité
et rendre le recyclage des déchets
économiquement plus attractifs que leur
élimination
cette réforme elle s'inscrit dans un
équilibre global dans lequel de
nouvelles capacités financières ont été
données aux collectivités pour investir
pour s'adapter à travers plusieurs
mécanismes de soutien comme l'allègement
à 5,5% de la TVA sur les activités de
tri de recyclage et de prévention des
déchets la réduction des frais de
gestion perçue par l'État sur la taxe
d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères
incitatifs la mise en place aussi de
nouvelles filières à responsabilité
élargie des producteurs au-delà des
mesures de réduction des déchets la
politique de l'économie circulaire que
nous menons réoriente la prise en charge
des déchets de plus en plus fortement
vers les fabricants et les distributeurs
des produits dans une logique de Power
payer
le principe de responsabilité élargie
des producteurs constituent un axe
structurant notre politique dans ce
domaine les producteurs qui mettent sur
le marché certains produits sont rendus
responsables de financer et où
d'organiser la prévention et la gestion
des déchets issus de ces produits en fin
de vie ils verse pour cela une
contribution financière à un
éco-organisme qui met en oeuvre en
contrepartie des actions de prévention
et de gestion des déchets d'ici 2030 ce
sont 6 milliards d'euros que
représenteront l'ensemble de ces
filières reps pour réduire les coûts de
la réparation des produits cela doit
permettre d'augmenter leur durée de vie
de développer le réemploi et les
produire reconditionnés et aussi de
recycler les déchets
ces filières repent elles permettent
également aux collectivités d'être
déchargées de la prise en charge d'un
certain nombre de déchets ménagers et de
bénéficier de compensation financière
les ambitions ont ainsi été renforcées
par les 12 filières reps historiques et
les 11 nouvelles filières répons qui ont
été programmées entre 2021 et 2025 par
exemple concernant le bâtiment c'est 42
millions de tonnes de déchets qui sont
produits chaque année c'est autant que
tous les déchets de l'ensemble des
ménages français une nouvelle rép pour
les produits et matériaux de
construction du secteur du bâtiment a
donc été lancée ce sont ainsi quatre
éco-organismes que l'on vient d'agréer
pour une entrée en vigueur entre 2023 et
2027 cette filière du bâtiment atteindra
2,5 milliards d'euros dans 6 ans pour
financer la prise en charge gratuite des
déchets et créer de nouvelles
déchetteries et recyclées
l'objectif est de développer dès 2023 le
réemploi et le recyclage des déchets du
bâtiment mais aussi de mettre fin aux
décharges sauvages grâce à la reprise
gratuite des déchets et la création de
nouvelles déchetteries accessibles aux
artisans et au TPE
parmi les secteurs dans lesquels nous
devons accélérer le secteur du textile
et l'un des plus impactants
le textile représente 450
000 tonnes jetés dans les poubelles
chaque année soit 45 tour Eiffel c'est
près de 250 000 tonnes qui sont
collectés et triés chaque année mais la
grande majorité est malheureusement
incinérée plutôt que valorisé
l'empreinte carbone de notre
consommation textile est de près de 30
millions de tonnes équivalent carbone
c'est pour répondre à ces défis que j'ai
lancé il y a quelques jours quelques
semaines donc c'était début octobre une
grande consultation pour transformer en
six ans la filière textile afin
d'ailleurs d'abord de financer la
réparation ensuite leur emploi mais
aussi le déploiement d'une filière
industrielle de recyclage est textile en
France c'est une rêve qui peut atteindre
600 millions d'euros sur la période pour
favoriser la réparation le réemploi le
recyclage et 350 millions pour avantager
via des bonus les produits éco-conçus
nous agissons aussi sur les emballages
ménagers la filière repemballage ménagée
représente un milliard d'euros en 2023
pour financer la collecte le tri le
recyclage et notamment des plastiques
parmi les nouveaux financements on
compte 62 millions d'euros pour les
nouvelles poubelles de rue et 100
millions d'euros pour accompagner les
collectivités dans le nettoyage des
espaces publics sur le plastique tout
très confondu 4 millions de tonnes sont
jetés chaque année en majorité des
emballages et le recyclage de tous les
plastiques reste insuffisants et
seulement 20% à ce jour sont recyclés
donc certaines solutions qui ont pu être
écartées dans un passé récent sont
désormais assez mûrs pour être abordés
je pense à la consigne en premier lieu
il s'agira dans les prochains mois de
mettre en place une méthode de
concertation avec les acteurs privés
avec les collectivités territoriales et
avec les parlementaires pour y parvenir
je souhaite également souligner d'autres
actions notamment le plan national de
résorption des décharges littorales
présentant des risques de relargage des
déchets en mer dans le cadre du
lancement de ce fond de ce plan donc il
y a un fond annuel de 30 millions
d'euros qui a été mis en place dès 2022
il sera renouvelé chaque année pendant
10 ans le temps de la réalisation du
plan national il sera géré par la dame
séviat se fondent réhabilitation des
anciennes décharges communales
présentant un risque de relargage de
déchets en mer qui sera financé cela
concerne les diagnostics également
l'assistance financière mais aussi les
travaux
j'insiste également sur la charte zéro
déchet sur les plages que nous portons
avec l'Association nationale des élus du
littoral elle compte aujourd'hui 75
communes adhérentes et je souhaite
qu'elles soient 500 en 2025 vous le
voyez des budgets inédits sont dédiés à
la transition écologique avec ici la
préservation de la biodiversité et la
mise en place d'une économie circulaire
performante je vais avoir besoin de vous
besoin de votre soutien pour accompagner
l'ensemble de ces politiques
volontaristes je suis à l'écoute de
toutes vos questions merci à vous
merci madame la ministre et compter sur
notre soutien pour porter haut c'est
politique de protection et de
développement de la biodiversité
pour le groupe Renaissance la parole est
à Anthony Bros
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je tiens au nom du groupe
Renaissance à vous remercier pour votre
présence de votre commission aujourd'hui
et pour nous avoir détaillé les actions
que vous comptez mener au sein du
Secrétariat des tâches chargés de
l'écologie la protection de la nature
est un enjeu crucial et mes propos se
concentreront sur le traitement de nos
déchets et leur valorisation qui nous
concerne toutes et tous lors du
précédent quinquennat deux grandes lois
ont été votées climat est résilience et
anti-gaspillage pour une économie
circulaire les avancées obtenues sont
importantes il convient de les saluer
récemment notre commission encore été
saisie lors de la niche parlementaire de
nos collègues du groupe modem d'une
proposition de loi sur les plastiques
dangereux pour l'environnement et la
santé
ces préoccupations sur le recyclage et
la valorisation des déchets sur ton cœur
de nos nombreuses politiques publiques
et infusent de plus en plus dans
l'opinion nos collectivités sont en
première ligne au regard du respect de
la loi de l'objectif fixé par la loi
transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte qui impose de réduire
de 50 % l'enfouissement des déchets
décide 2025 les syndicats de déchets se
tournent ainsi vers de nouvelles
filières de valorisation à l'instar de
la production de combustibles solides
récupération le CSR cherche à valoriser
des déchets non dangereux qu'ils ne
peuvent être recyclés en permettant une
valorisation énergétique performante en
chaleur et en électricité en
substitution d'énergie fossiles ainsi
madame la ministre pouvez-vous nous
indiquer de quelle manière le
gouvernement accompagne les territoires
dans cette transite transition vers de
nouveaux modes de recyclage en outre
vous l'avez dit un tiers de nos déchets
qui ne sont pas triés par les ménages
sont des biodéchets c'est un gisement
non négligeable qu'il faut maintenant
détourner de l'élimination en vue d'une
économie circulaire de la matière
organique la loi prévoit que les tous
les particuliers nous devons disposer
d'une solution pratique de tri à la
source à compter du 1er janvier 2024 les
retours d'expérience collectent
spécifiques dans les zones denses ou
compostage en ruralité montrent que les
collectivités qui se sont engagées sont
satisfaites la collecte séparée des
déchets alimentaires à souvent l'intérêt
d'augmenter les performances de tri des
autres flux aussi pouvez-vous compléter
ce que le financement que vous aviez
indiqué les 220 millions d'euros pour
l'ADEME pour accompagner les
collectivités qui doivent se mettre en
ordre de bataille en vue de la
généralisation prévue au 1er janvier
2024 merci je vous remercie pour le
groupe rassemblement national la parole
est à Christophe Barthès merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues quand la transition
écologique devait être un moteur de
progrès pour beaucoup de compatriotes
elle rime avec dépenses sacrifices et
contraintes votre écologie est une
écologie punitive les Français se
sacrifient et doivent payer toujours
plus parce qu'il se chauffent au fioul
parce qu'il se déplace en voiture un
autre d'ailleurs une de vos priorités
250 millions d'euros pour un nouveau
plan vélo le bilan est là la stratégie
énergétique du gouvernement appauvrit
les Français et ce n'est pas à eux de
payer vos erreurs
pour nombreux pour nous sommes pardon
menacés de coupure d'électricité dans un
pays développé et cela ne choque pas le
gouvernement réponse madame borne à
l'Assemblée c'est à cause de la guerre à
l'Ukraine quel sera la prochaine excuse
devant l'accélération de la transition
écologique brutale pour nombre de
portefeuilles il est répondu qu'il faut
atteindre les objectifs énergétiques
objectif pour la plupart imposé par
l'Union européenne je vous le demande
madame la ministre les Français sont
irresponsables de ces objectifs dans une
situation exceptionnelle ne pourrait-on
pas mettre en place des mesures
exceptionnelles aujourd'hui l'angoisse
nos concitoyens et de passer l'hiver et
pour certains s'ils vont y parvenir
pensez à nos anciens et à leur mère
retraite pour eux le chauffage n'est pas
un luxe mais moyenne resté en vie
la leçon du col roulé et du Tancarville
est un scandale de la part des
responsable de cette situation au nom
d'une doctrine de gauche vous avez
sacrifié la filière nucléaire pour les
énergies intermittentes l'objectif des
SIPR proposé par le gouvernement n'est
pas suffisant le RN propose d'en bâtir
20 pour assurer notre souveraineté et
une bicarbonisation réelle de nos
énergies si les coupures d'électricité
deviennent courante pourra-t-on avoir la
douche chaude ou allumer son four pour
faire manger nos enfants après l'école
ce sont là les questions concrètes des
Français madame la ministre
envisagez-vous de revoir vos priorités
je vous remercie
pour le groupe la France insoumise du
peste la parole est à Manon meunier
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre la loi de Deschamps est
emblématique du déclin des oiseaux
communs au milieu agricole sont déclin
en France et l'an mais régulier
initialement identifiant statut
préoccupation mineur l'espèce est
désormais classée dans la catégorie
quasi menacée voici un petit extrait de
la liste rouge des oiseaux menacés de
France métropolitaine de l'UICN
ui CN dont la France a accueilli le
Congrès il y a deux ans dans le volet
biodiversité de votre projet de loi des
finances c'est également évoqué le
programme stock suivi temporel des
oiseaux communs c'est en effet
l'indicateur que vous avez retenu pour
suivre l'évolution de la biodiversité
ordinaire alors ce programme stock nous
apprend que l'alouette des champs a vu
sa population chuter de 21,9% entre 2001
et 2019 bref de nombreux indices qui se
trouvaient sous les yeux du gouvernement
et qui aurait pu vous alerter sur le
fait que votre décision relative à
l'autorisation de la chasse de plus de
100 000 Alouettes des champs sans même
prendre en compte les décisions du
Conseil d'État ni les alertes
d'associations comme la Ligue pour la
Protection des Oiseaux est un non-sens
psychologique on se demande donc en
faveur de quoi ou de qui le ministère de
la transition écologique assume de
prendre ses décisions si ce n'est pas
pour l'intérêt général la préservation
de cette biodiversité dite ordinaire et
pourtant primordiale sur le terrain de
nombreuses associations naturalistes
exercent un travail méticuleux d'études
et de protection de cette biodiversité
et dans nos écoles sur nos écrans encore
de nombreuses associations nous
informent et sensibilisent pour la
protection de notre environnement or ces
associations comme la plupart du monde
associatifs d'ailleurs indispensable à
la bonne santé de notre société alerte
maintenant depuis plusieurs années sur
la diminution des subventions qui sont
destinées à leur fonctionnement et
dénoncent un système par appel à projet
qui les oblige à rentrer dans les cases
et qui ne correspondent pas toujours aux
réalités du terrain or ce n'est pas le
budget insignifiant prévu pour le volet
biodiversité en tant que tel de
seulement 300 millions d'euros pour
toute la France je le rappelle qui va
permettre de régler ce problème et ce
n'est pas non plus le nouvel amendement
amendement déposé dans le projet de loi
des finances proposant la suppression de
l'avantage fiscal aux associations
lanceuse d'alerte qui va arranger la
situation c'est amendement menace encore
davantage la survie et la bonne
réalisation des missions de nos
associations de protection de la nature
nous attendons donc une position claire
du gouvernement contre cette amendement
et la mise en place d'un programme
détaillé de soutien aux associations de
protection de la biodiversité je vous
remercie merci pour le groupe socialiste
et apparentés la parole est à Stéphane
de Lautrec
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre tout d'abord je vous remercie
pour votre propos très précis liminaire
et pour votre présence cet après-midi
devant notre commission et je salue
votre engagement sur des sujets qui nous
sont chers et je tenais à vous dire
qu'on sera à vos côtés pour travailler
et faire avancer la cause tout au long
de notre processus législatif je
voudrais revenir juste sur quelques
points que vous avez abordés dans votre
feuille de route très orienté sur le
sujet de l'économie circulaire tout
d'abord sur la question du fond vert et
de son articulation avec les autres
financements mobilisables par les
collectivités à savoir les financements
de l'ADEME quelquefois la dotr la DSI
etc donc peut-être mieux comprendre
comment tout cela va va fonctionner vous
évoquiez la trajectoire TGAP nous a pas
échappé sur les territoires
l'augmentation de cette TGAP de la
recette aussi qu'elle
imaginaire seriez-vous favorables comme
nous l’appelons de nos vœux dans le
cadre du PLF à l'affectation plus
importante voire totale de cette TGAP
dont le produit ne cesse donc de croître
comme je disais à l'ADEME pour
accompagner les porteurs de projets
qu'ils soient public ou privés dans le
champ de l'économie circulaire tout
comme seriez-vous favorables à des
mesures d'incitation des collectivités
performantes avec des critères
évidemment à définir par un abaissement
de cette TGAP de manière à peut-être
inciter celle qui ne le sont pas à
s'engager plus facilement dans le
processus sur la question du du réemploi
recyclage je vous évoquiez la TVA
réduite sur certaines activités la
réparation échappe à cette TVA réduite
de 5,5 me semble-t-il y seriez-vous
favorable et enfin sur la tarification
incitative c'est un vrai levier efficace
pour réduire la quantité d'ordures
ménagères résiduelles certaines hésitent
à la mettre en oeuvre en l'absence de
critères sociaux seriez-vous favorables
à faire évoluer cette possibilité merci
Madame la Ministre merci chers collègues
pour le groupe horizon et parenté la
parole est à Anne-Cécile violence
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues tout d'abord
madame la ministre merci pour votre
présence régulière au sein de notre
commission et la présentation de votre
feuille de route
alors permettez-moi tout d'abord de nous
réjouir au nom du groupe horizon de
l'augmentation du budget global de votre
ministère et de ses missions ce projet
de loi de finances prend en compte toute
l'urgence de la crise environnementale
et traduit concrètement l'engagement du
gouvernement en matière de transition
écologique sachez que notre groupe
répondra présent à votre présent appel
de demande de soutien
je pense notamment aux 2 milliards de
pour les agences de l'eau en 2003 afin
de mieux répartir et anticiper les
usages mieux anticiper les crises mieux
sécuriser les approvisionnements
vous l'avez compris ma question portera
sur les enjeux de l'eau c'est un bien
commun de l'humanité qu'il nous faut
préserver une ressource renouvelable
mais pas illimité comme la souligna de
nombreuses reprises monsieur Christophe
Béchu dans la continuité de ma question
gouvernement adressée cet été en pleine
période de canicule et de sécheresse de
nombreux territoires connaissent
toujours des épisodes de forte tension
pour l'accès à l'eau encore aujourd'hui
avec des restrictions d'usage régies par
arrêté préfectoral
toujours à l'oeuvre tout comme des
épisodes de pollution dangereuses pour
nos écosystèmes aquatiques maintenant
que nous avons pris conscience de la
nécessité d'agir au plus vite et sur le
long terme pour préserver nos ressources
en eau il est temps de mettre en œuvre
les mesures indispensables pour prévenir
ces sécheresses et ne plus se trouver
acculé à des mesures uniquement
palliatives ainsi vous l'avez rappelé le
plan d'adaptation et de planification de
la gestion de l'eau lancer le 29
septembre dernier est une excellente
nouvelle nous le soutenons et le
suivrons avec attention pouvez-vous nous
en dire davantage madame le ministre sur
la méthodologie envisagée et en quoi ce
plan pourra répondre justement à cette
anticipation je vous remercie merci
chers collègues pour le groupe
écologiste nups la parole est à Lisa
mélo
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues l'eau est un
bien commun et rien ne justifie qu'elle
soit privatisée évidemment la situation
climatique la graviation et la
récurrence des sécheresses nécessite que
l'on gère les usages de l'eau
collectivement dans mon département la
proposition faite pour gérer les usages
de l'eau consiste en la privatisation de
la ressource au bénéfice de quelques
agriculteurs industriels qui épuisent
nos terres et détruisent notre santé et
ce dans le seul but d'acheter la paix au
détriment des générations présentes et
futures je m'explique l'État via le
préfet va forcer la construction de 30
Méga bassines ou réserve de substitution
sur le bassin du Clain au bénéfice
d'environ 153 irrigans pour information
sur ce bassin du Clain on dénombre 350
irrigants
un protocole d'accord a été élaboré pour
mettre tout le monde autour de la table
mais ce protocole même dans sa seconde
version ne satisfait personne ni la
Chambre d'Agriculture ni les
associations ni la Fédération de Pêche
je vous rappelle au passage que
l'instruction gouvernementale du 7 mai
2019 préconise d'accélérer les
laboration de projets de territoire pour
la gestion de l'eau ou ptge mais dans la
Vienne aucun ptgen n'a été réalisé
pensez-vous qu'on peut décréter qu'une
minorité d'irrigant peut s'accaparer la
ressource en eau sans même évaluer
l'impact que cela aura sur la capacité à
fournir de l'eau potable en été et je
précise que dans la Vienne à plusieurs
endroits on a été à deux doigts de
couper l'alimentation en eau potable
pour les habitants et les habitants cet
été et on est encore en situation
critique
trouvez-vous normal que les deux tiers
des coups de ces bassines de
privatisation de l'eau soit financées
par de l'argent public
42% du coût des bassines est prévu
d'être supporté par l'Agence de l'Eau
Loire Bretagne alors même que l'on sait
que les agences de l'eau manquent déjà
de moyens pour assurer leur mission
madame la ministre il est temps
d'arrêter les petits arrangements entre
amis il est temps d'enfants consacré
votre énergie à la protection à la
gestion de l'eau et pour cela oui les
agriculteurs ont besoin d'aide alors
aidons les vraiment à opérer leur
transition agroécologique pour qu'il
puisse continuer à nous nourrir avec des
aliments de qualité au lieu de les
maintenir dans leur dépendance à une
agriculture mortifère qui épuise et
pollue notre bien commun l'eau
merci chers collègues pour le groupe les
républicains la parole est à Nicolas Rey
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre 2022 restera l'année d'une
prise de conscience majeure pour les
Français sécheresses incendie crise
énergétique dépendances aux énergies
fossiles le lien entre les enjeux
d'écologie de pouvoir d'achat de
souveraineté ont été mis sur le devant
de la scène notre groupe est favorable à
défendre le principe pollueur-payeur à
ce titre j'aurais deux questions à vous
poser vous avez parlé du fond vert
pouvez-vous nous préciser aussi les
critères et de la répartition
géographique qui pourra être prévue pour
ce fond une question un peu plus précise
également est-ce que vous prévoyez que
le ce dispositif puis servir ou
financement de dispositif anti-grêle
puisque des intempéries violentes de
grève ont touché de nombreux
départements
enfin sur le sujet de l'eau
la question de l'eau est en effet un
sujet majeur qui a été soulevé à de
nombreuses reprises ces derniers mois
en réalité aujourd'hui 90% des eaux
usées sont traitées en France mais moins
d'un pourcent sont réutilisés
en Israël c'est 80% titre de comparaison
auriez-vous quel est votre feuille de
route en la matière en matière de
réutilisation des eaux usées
merci cher collègue pour le groupe
démocrate modem et à parenté la parole
est indépendante la parole est à haute
du quai merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre prochainement de
grands rendez-vous
vont avoir lieu la cop27 avec une
priorité réunir les 100 milliards de
dollars pour parents nécessaires pour
couvrir les coûts d'adaptation et de
transition des pays en développement
conformément à l'accord de Paris la COP
15 biodiversité qui doit permettre
d'établir un nouveau cadre mondial pour
mettre un terme à l'érosion de la
biodiversité des sites d'ici à 2030 face
à de grands engagements qui trace un cap
commun il nous faut à notre échelle
transformée nos ambitions dans la
réalité dans notre quotidien un des
enjeux sur lequel j'aimerais inciter
celui de la préservation de la
biodiversité dans nos communes les
besoins de rappeler les effets positifs
de la nature en ville ils sont multiples
on constate malheureusement que la
séquence éviter réduire compensée n'est
pas suffisamment prise en compte dans
les projets d'aménagement du territoire
subsiste en effet une forte tendance à
privilégier la compensation plutôt que
la réservation avec les effets négatifs
que cela entraîne quelle place pour ces
enjeux dans votre feuille de route
madame la ministre dans cette même
thématique pouvez-vous nous dire
également où en est la rédaction du
décret d'application de l'article l350-3
du code de l'environnement votez dans la
loi 3DS concernant les allées et
alignement d'armes pour d'arbres
pour terminer j'aimerais revenir sur la
loi économie circulaire que nous avons
voté il y a un peu plus de deux ans et
demi vous avez madame la ministre lancé
récemment large consultation avec les
acteurs du textile pour améliorer les
performances de la filière REP dont les
résultats sont insuffisants pouvez-vous
nous en dire un peu plus sur le déroulé
de ces consultations avez-vous déjà
identifié des axes d'amélioration
au-delà des filières existantes il y en
a de nouvelles qui doivent se mettre en
place notamment celle du BTP prévue à
l'origine pour 2022 elle est finalement
attendue pour le 1er janvier 2023 les
enjeux les enjeux sont conséquents face
à un secteur qui produit plus de 42
millions de tonnes de déchets par an en
France
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus sur la
mise en place de cette filière ainsi que
les moyens mis en oeuvre par l'État je
vous en remercie
merci chers collègues pour la gauche
démocratique
madame monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre bon encore l'eau et par rapport
à son usage prioritaire l'eau potable et
l'assainissement en jeu de santé et de
sécurité publique majeure or les deux
entités en responsabilité les agences de
l'eau et les services publics d'eau et
d'assainissement sont confrontés les
unes comme les autres à des fragilités
budgétaires sans cesse accru qui leur
interdisent de déployer toutes
l'efficacité nécessaire à leur action
dans le champ de la qualité et
l'accessibilité de la ressource alors le
plan quinquennal au 19 24 appellent les
agences à agir dans le cadre d'une
enveloppe inférieure à celle de la
période précédente c'est selon nous un
non-sens au regard de l'accélération
sans précédent des conséquences du
réchauffement climatique sur le grand
cycle de l'eau pourtant prioriser même
si Lisa la indiqué un certain nombre
d'actions sont soumis au feu de la
critique d'action financement sont
soumis au feu de la critique au niveau
des services publics eau et
assainissement et bien eux-mêmes et bien
dépendant des agences de jour quand leur
financement
peine à obtenir le soutien nécessaire à
la modernisation et à la régénération
des infrastructures
d'approvisionnement
et à la en eau contribuant par la même
également à la frilosité constatée en
matière de tarification sociale
progressive au niveau de l'eau
le cadre et la trajectoire budgétaire de
ces entités de plus en plus tendues que
comptez-vous entreprendre pour
déverrouiller structurellement ce
véritable carcan financier sur les
agences de l'eau et les services publics
eau et assainissement
merci chers
et territoires la parole est à déjà
Benjamin ça tuile merci monsieur le
Président Madame le Ministre deux
minutes trois questions la première
concernant le fond vert il a un peu
tardé à nous être communiqué puisque il
y a un décalage de 15 jours par rapport
au PLF je parle du budget vert pardon le
budget vert dans ce budget vert on a
connaissance des dépenses dites brunes
et il a été annoncé par le gouvernement
qu'il y avait globalement une stabilité
de ses dépenses brunes dans le cadre de
ce budget vert or si on regarde dans la
réalité de la non prise en compte de
toutes les dépenses du bouclier
tarifaire on peut considérer que en coût
brut cela viendrait impacter encore
davantage et donc si je fais rapide vous
avez annoncé une stabilité des dépenses
brunes dans le cadre du budget vert
est-ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer il
nous semble nous que si on intègre
l'ensemble des dépenses liées ou qui est
à y faire on est bien au-delà le
deuxième question concernant les TGAP
vous avez rappelé la trajectoire
d'augmentation des recettes pas très
bien l'autre impacte
c'est les difficultés potentielles pour
les EPCI de faire face à ces
augmentations de TGAP puisque si pour
nous c'est une bonne nouvelle pour les
EPCI c'est une dépense supplémentaire
qui va falloir accès accepter de
consentir et donc on peut considérer que
la vraie question pour nous c'est de
savoir comment vous organisez le travail
avec les territoires pour que le
recyclage avance d'une part éclatée gap
n'acte pas la capacité d'investissement
des territoires et particulièrement de
PCI qui sont déjà frappés par la crise
énergétique et enfin en 25 secondes
revenir à l'instant sur la question de
la consigne puisque vous l'avez évoqué
très brièvement dans votre propos vous
n'avez pas une concertation à venir avec
les collectivités est-ce que le timing
annoncé de 2023 va être tenue et dans
quelles conditions vous allez organisé
ces échanges de manière à ce que les
territoires et le sentiment légitime
d'être entendu et accompagné dans cette
démarche je vous remercie
merci chers collègues je crois que tous
les amateurs ont pu s'exprimer la
ministre je vous laisse le soin de
répondre à ces moments de question
merci monsieur le Président je suis gâté
en effet j'ai un certain nombre de
questions et les sujets sont extrêmement
divers je vais essayer comme je crois
l'avoir été à peu près lors de la
précédente audition être la plus la plus
complète possible et vous m'excuserez
s'il y a des manques mais il y a eu
beaucoup de questions dans des questions
donc je voilà il peut il est possible
que j'oublie j'oublie certaines choses
alors déjà je vais commencer par par
Monsieur Bros
la priorité vous savez du gouvernement
est de réduire la production de déchets
moi je l'ai expliqué évidemment de
développer le recyclage et également la
réutilisation
au détriment de l'élimination des
déchets donc état collectivité mais
également aussi producteur et
consommateurs on a un objectif collectif
c'est de diviser par deux les quantités
de déchets non dangereux mises en
décharge d'ici 2025
et après c'est stoppé la mise en
décharge des déchets non dangereux
encore valorisables donc pour atteindre
cet objectif évidemment le tri à la
source des biodéchets est une
opportunité pour favoriser l'économie
circulaire également contribuer à la
lutte contre le changement climatique
mais aussi soutenir des pratiques
agricoles qui sont durables donc la
valorisation des biodéchets permet vous
savez de produire du biogaz donc vous
l'avez d'ailleurs expliqué en
remplacement du de gaz naturel ou du
compost agricole en remplacement en
remplacement de d'engrais fabriqués avec
du gaz naturel donc c'est donc aussi un
enjeu de souveraineté énergétique et
pour en faciliter le déploiement le
gouvernement a déjà soutenu plus de 400
projets dans tous les territoires et ce
qui représente plus de 100 millions
d'euros d'aide engagés sur la période
juste de 2021 2022 et ça c'était dans le
cadre du fond économie circulaire puis
ensuite du plan de relance donc pour
poursuivre ce soutien qui a porté aux
collectivités le gouvernement prévoit en
2023 de mobiliser des soutiens
supplémentaires dans le cadre du fond
d'accélération la transition écologique
dans les territoires celui qu'on appelle
le fond vert et ce fond permettra ainsi
d'accompagner financièrement les
collectivités pour mettre en place la
collecte et la valorisation de
biodéchets donc au delà de ces soutiens
spécifiques au lieu des chaînes
nouvelles capacité financières ont été
données aux collectivités pour investir
et les accompagner vers une gestion plus
circulaire de leurs déchets je l'ai cité
tout à l'heure l'allègement à 5% de la
TVA sur les activités de tri la
réduction des frais de gestion perçus
par l'État sur la taxe d'enlèvement des
ordures ménagères incitatives ou encore
la mise en place de nouvelles filières
REP dont je vous ai donné le détail on a
aussi le renforcement du fond économie
circulaire de l'ADEME avec plus de 440
sont 40 millions d'euros supplémentaires
en 2023 donc vous voyez le monsieur le
député le gouvernement est aux côtés des
collectivités pour les accompagner dans
cette dans cette transition
donc évidemment si vous avez entendu
dans mon propos luminaire que c'était un
sujet extrêmement important pour le
ministère
monsieur Barthez qui est parti
c'est dommage j'avais envie de
ce sera juste le temps de te le poster
alors
concernant la question de Manon meunier
alors vous m'avez posé plusieurs quais
il y avait plusieurs thèmes le premier
qui concernait
les chasses traditionnelles et notamment
le fait d'avoir accepté donc donc de
signer l'arrêté donc vous savez que
c'est un dossier qui est un sujet qui
est complexe qui fait écho dans dans
nombreuses régions de France notamment
l'est et sud-ouest de la France où elle
se pratique plus qu'ailleurs et celles
qui posait le plus de difficultés vous
savez c'est la chasse à la glue qui est
définitivement abandonné
ces chasses traditionnelles elles sont
des chasses je le rappelle sans armes à
feu avec des pratiques traditionnelles
qui posent principalement le sujet de la
sélectivité ces chats peuvent être
sélectives ou pas mais sont non létales
en général en grande majorité pour les
espèces qui seraient capturées
accidentellement donc ces chaises ces
chasses elles ont un impact faible sur
la biodiversité des espèces concernées
et sont chassés dans des quantités plus
importantes que dans les chasses
conventionnelles elles présentent en
outre une dimension culturelle forte
dans les territoires où elles sont
pratiquées alors le cadre réglementaire
ancien en vigueur depuis 1989 ne répond
pas à toutes les exigences de la
légalité actuelle c'est donc pourquoi
nous avons donc procédé à cet été à une
refonte intégrale d'arrêter cadres en
vigueur depuis donc je le disais à 1989
prenons en compte les décisions récentes
du Conseil d'État donc les nouveaux
arrêtés encadrant la pratique des
chasses traditionnelles ont été
préparées en apportant directement dans
ces arrêtés cadres toutes les
justifications demandées par la
directive
oiseau de l'alouette des champs dont
vous parliez au moment au moyen de pente
donc ce sont des filets pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas la pratique et de mattol
pour les cages pièges dans le Sud-Ouest
il fait aucun doute qu'une nouvelle
demande de suspension de ces pratiques
sera demandée par par leurs opposants
le ministre c'était engagé à attendre
l'éclairage du Conseil d'État pour
renforcer la qualité des textes et
procéder à une meilleure visibilité
juridique mais il faut quand même
comprendre aussi que on est sans réponse
du Conseil d'État depuis la demande qui
a été faite les chats commençant on a
décidé de publier ces textes pour 2022
2023 et on a bon espoir d'avoir une
réponse du Conseil d'État qui ne serait
tardait à présent maintenant le la on
attend et on attendait vraiment les
résultats du Conseil d'État et sauf que
elles se font attendre donc on ne peut
pas non plus laisser des chasseurs qui
ont envie de pratiquer dans de bonnes
conditions
rester sans réponse et donc de geler
l'ensemble d'une année de chasse
traditionnelle donc c'est pourquoi on a
pris cette décision vous m'avez
interrogé également sur le financement
des associations
donc ça passe à la fois par l'ofb mais
aussi par le programme 113 dont je
parlais tout à l'heure paysage au
biodiversité
nous augmentons leur dotation je les
exprimé tout à l'heure et y compris pour
le fonctionnement pour certaines d'entre
elles et notamment les Conservatoires
d'espaces naturels en bénéficient
bénéficieront notamment d'une dotation
supplémentaire de 500 millions d'euros
donc pour les associations gestionnaires
d'air protégés les crédits sont
conservés et seront complétés par le
fond vert qui consacrera 50 millions
d'euros à la gestion des aires protégées
et il n'y a donc pas qu'un système
d'appels de à projet mais bien aussi un
système de pérenne stable pour
financer justement des projets et l'idée
c'est que d'avoir qu'elle soit stable
voire même en hausse pour leur
fonctionnement
ensuite
j'ai une question très différente
de Monsieur le Député de l'autre aide
déjà je voulais vous remercier pour vous
mon encouragement
parce que j'ai souligne quand ils sont
voilà ça fait du bien aussi de recevoir
voilà donc vous m'avez interrogé
particulièrement sur la TGAP
donc vous l'avez dit elle a elle a pour
vocation d'inciter donc tous les acteurs
à privilégier le réemploi et le
recyclage à la place des décharges
une baisse de la de la TGAP ou une
rétribution de la TGAP qu'on sent
condition elle pourrait supprimer cette
incitation à éviter les décharges donc
pour soutenir les collectivités et aussi
les projets alternatifs aux décharge le
gouvernement choisi de privilégier les
financements avec le fond économie
circulaire qui est à hauteur de 210
millions d'euros par an et également le
fond vert voilà
donc ça c'était pour Monsieur
delautraite ensuite il y avait la
question de la députée violent pour
horizon vous m'avez interrogé sur le
sujet de l'eau merci aussi pour vos mots
d'encouragement donc sur l'eau
bon on partage tous le diagnostic c'est
désormais c'est bien sur notre
territoire qui est touché par le manque
d'eau et le déficit structurel des
nappes et nous l'avons vu cet été avec
la sécheresse y compris dans des
territoires jusque là qui étaient très
peu concernés donc même si nous avons
déjà une politique de l'eau
particulièrement forte
nous devons aller plus loin sur la
réponse et c'est bien l'objectif du
chantier que j'ai lancé à Marseille le
29 septembre dernier avec Christophe
BECHU et Agnès firmalomodo en présence
de Monsieur le Président il y avait
également les présidents du Comité
national de l'eau et des comités de
bassin donc l'objectif c'est de
s'engager dans une réelle transition et
il y a trois axes le premier c'est le
sujet de la sobriété des usages de l'eau
avec un objectif de baisse des
prélèvements de 10 % d'ici 2025 et de 25
% d'ici 2035 cela implique de clarifier
les règles de partage de la ressource
les efforts collectifs à consentir pour
faire avec moins d'eau donc c'est pas
évident mais il faut que il faut que
nous arrivions à atteindre ces objectifs
et ensuite nous devons garantir l'accès
à une eau potable de qualité donc ça va
impliquer un effort important dans
l'entretien des réseaux il faut aussi
aller plus loin dans la protection des
quatre tâches prioritaires dans certains
territoires nous sommes pas au
rendez-vous et nous sommes en retard
donc sur ce sujet donc il va falloir
qu'on aille plus loin et c'est ce que
j'ai dit notamment sur une des dernières
réunions que j'ai eu pas plus tard
qu'hier avec avec le
le comité de bassin de d'Adour des ours
sur Garonne voilà
nos concitoyens donc ont des attentes
attentes légitimes sur ce sujet et il
faut qu'on puisse y répondre
et enfin nous devons restaurer le grand
cycle de l'eau en nous appuyant sur les
solutions fondées sur la nature
également la restauration des
continuités écologiques et aussi sur la
désimperméabilisation donc en termes de
méthode l'idée c'est pas d'avoir un
grand plan d'État mais vraiment d'avoir
un plan collectif d'aller chercher les
bonnes pratiques et surtout de consulter
le terrain et ceux qui connaissent le
sujet de la gestion de l'eau il y a
évidemment plein de bonnes pratiques et
il faut qu'on arrive à faire émaner de
ça sur les territoires donc l'idée c'est
pas de repartir
de rien c'est de miser sur les travaux
qui ont déjà été réalisés je pense aux
acides de l'eau et du varen agricole et
on va s'appuyer aussi sur les instances
de gouvernance et les compétences
existantes donc voilà on a sollicité les
acteurs et on attend leur retour d'ici à
peu de temps en tous les cas je vous
assure qu'ils sont déjà mobilisés
j'avais une question de madame belluco
vous m'avez interrogé sur
le sujet des retenus d'eau le sujet de
l'eau globalement des retenus d'eau et
particulièrement sur votre territoire
donc on a la nécessité d'avoir un retour
à l'équilibre des bassins versants
[Musique]
l'idée c'est évidemment donc moi j'en ai
parlé justement juste avant avec Madame
madame violon l'idée c'est d'avoir un de
repenser en fait notre gestion de l'eau
on a
plusieurs problématiques et la
problématique de
la gestion par le secteur agricole en
ayant mais n'est pas le seul le sujet on
peut pas imaginer penser la gestion de
l'eau en focalisant uniquement sur le
secteur agricole on a le secteur
industriel et également les ménages
globalement donc sur le secteur agricole
il y a les sujets des bassines c'est un
sujet qui est souvent
urticant pour le ministère de la
transition écologique parce que en effet
on regarde avec
voilà beaucoup de perplexité souvent les
projets qui qui sont proposés malgré
tout il y a des projets qui peuvent être
intéressants en fonction
du territoire c'est pour ça qu'on
s'interdit pas de regarder certains
projets vous avez raison qu'il faut des
ptge il faut les généraliser sur
l'ensemble du territoire et je regrette
comme vous que la Vienne n'en est pas et
c'est un sujet que je vais regarder
évidemment avec attention parce que
c'est important qu'on est des ptge sur
l'ensemble du territoire
particulièrement moi ce que je vous
propose et c'est pas parce que je ne
veux pas répondre aujourd'hui c'est pour
avoir plus d'éléments sur
particulièrement les projets qui en
viennent et je me propose de revenir
enfin vous donner les éléments plus
précisément mais
l'idée c'est vraiment de se dire c'est
on ne fera pas simplement enfin c'est
pas parce qu'il y a un manque d'eau
qu'on va généraliser les bassines et en
faire partout sur le territoire et que
le secteur agricole reste dans la même
consommation d'eau ce n'est pas
envisageable parce qu'en fait ce n'est
pas tenable et donc il y a un certain
nombre de choses que nous devons mettre
en oeuvre et notamment on doit réfléchir
et c'est déjà le cas parce que je
partage cette ambition avec le min bien
sûr mais c'est quelque chose qu'entend
tout à fait aussi le ministre PHENO
c'est d'avancer sur une modification des
cultures en fonction des régions de
France on peut difficilement imaginer
que certains territoires qui connaissent
comme tous les autres mais
particulièrement les sud de la France
des le réchauffement climatique
continuent à produire autant de maïs par
exemple c'est un exemple qui a souvent
un exemple cité mais qui est un exemple
un exemple extrêmement probant voilà
mais je m'engage particulièrement sur le
sujet des bassines en vienne à revenir
vers vous sur le sujet parce que j'ai
pas assez d'éléments ma possession pour
pour vous faire une réponse complète
sinon j'avais aussi une question de
Monsieur le Député ré pour les
républicains oui
alors vous m'avez interrogé d'abord pour
savoir comment sera réparti donc le fond
vert et ce qui a une répartition
géographique alors il n'y a pas de
particulièrement de répartition
géographique ce sera en fonction des
projets le fond vert est un fond de 2
milliards d'euros je laisserai le
ministre Christophe Béchu donnait les
fléchages si le souhaitent des
différents pôles parce que c'est large
évidemment moi je vous parle de mon
portefeuille le portefeuille je vous ai
donné les grandes masses l'idée c'était
justement de fléchir pour s'assurer que
on va dire même si tous les projets sont
évidemment extrêmement importants mais
qui est pas on va dire un sujet une
cause qui soit davantage favorisée
qu'une autre et qu'on ait des fléchages
donc j'ai parlé plusieurs 20 millions
d'euros 35 millions d'euros mais ça vous
donnait aussi les objectifs qui étaient
celui du ministère les miens et du coup
donner la dynamique l'idée c'est
pourquoi je flèche aussi en imaginant
demain que quand il la collectivité qui
sera intéressée pour financer un projet
elle puisse directement s'adresser comme
genre de guichet qui pourra lui lui
donner ou pas en fonction évidemment du
projet et une fois que l'enveloppe
dédiée sera fondu on espère évidemment
et on imagine que les projets seront
nombreux ben on regardera à ce moment-là
en fonction des budgets restants mais
l'idée c'est de garder vigemment le
fléchage pour que on puisse avancer sur
les différents sujets les aires protégés
c'est très important mais j'ai aussi
très envie d'avancer sur les systèmes de
de mouillage écologique donc je ne peux
pas voilà aider davantage un sujet
plutôt qu'un autre par contre les aires
protégés ces 50 millions les le
mouillage écologique ça fait partie du
budget des 35 millions voilà c'est
quelques c'est comme ça que je souhaite
je souhaite fonctionner vous avez posé
la question sur les dispositifs
anti-grêle je veux vous répondre par la
négative pourquoi parce qu'en fait
on imagine enfin un dispositif en tigrel
prévient de conséquences de d'aller
acclimatiques et ne participe
malheureusement pas à la réduction de de
la dégradation de la biodiversité ou de
la réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre donc c'est pas sur ce
fond là que ça peut être fichier c'est
un accompagnement qui peut être imaginé
avec le avec le Mazar le ministère de
l'agriculture mais là pour le coup le
fond vert ne répondra pas à cette voilà
à cet objectif et vous avez aussi abordé
le sujet des eaux traitées
usés c'est un sujet justement important
parce que c'est une des solutions
justement qui doit être évoquée dans la
dans la gestion de l'eau évidemment je
vous ai parlé de sobriété mais on doit
aussi mieux réutiliser les eaux usées
traitées il est vrai qu'en France on est
assez mauvais élève voire pour dire
mauvais élève
on a pas engagé un certain nombre de
projets dans ce sens donc c'est pour ça
qu'on va donner une dynamique parce que
c'est ça fait partie évidemment des
solutions il y a aussi je crois des
normes sanitaires qui sont probablement
un peu drastiques on me donne des
exemples par exemple où on n'a pas
l'occasion de pouvoir arroser un stade
de foot parce qu'on a peut-être une
crainte qu'un enfant vienne
avoir contact avec sa bouche avec la
pelouse bon je crois qu'on va un peu
loin des fois dans certaines critères
sanitaires et donc voilà je pense qu'il
faut qu'on regarde avec le ministère de
la Santé avec les ARS comment on peut
soulager un petit peu les critères mais
il faut qu'on avance sur sur ces
solutions qui sont des solutions
efficaces et écologiques
j'ai une question également d'autres
Luquet sur alors plusieurs questions
vous avez
parlé de la protection de nos arbres
évidemment qui sont un enjeu important
pour le paysage la biodiversité mais
aussi pour notre patrimoine et je vous
sais très engagé sur le sujet la loi
biodiversité puis la loi 3DS sont venus
renforcer les outils dont nous disposons
pour veiller à leur protection et sur le
décret pour protéger les allées et les
alignements d'arbres décidez par la loi
3DS la consultation du public va être
lancée dans les prochains jours à venir
pour une durée de 28 jours tel que prévu
par le code de l'environnement et à
débouchera sur la saisine du Conseil
national d'évaluation des normes qui
représentent les collectivités puis sur
la saisine du Conseil d'État et le
gouvernement tient un objectif de
publication du décret d'application en
décembre 2022 ce décret ce texte pardon
est issu de concertation longue et je
souhaite maintenant en accélérer la
publication
concernant l'industrie du textile en
France c'était votre deuxième sujet
il représente 6 fois les émissions de
carbone du transport aérien donc c'est
extrêmement important et la nouvelle
filière REP deviendra accélérer le
passage à détectiles plus durables mieux
collecter mais aussi mieux recyclé c'est
ce que je vous disais dans mon propos
luminaire et sur la filière repextile
des réunions de concertation auront lieu
à rochlor au ministère le 13 et le 18
octobre et une commission raie pourra
lieu le 20 octobre et l'objectif c'est
de finaliser la feuille de route de la
filière début novembre avec un début
effectif d'ici la fin d'année donc cette
feuille de route nous permettra d'ici 6
ans d'améliorer grandement la gestion de
nos textiles ça peut paraître loin c'est
demain et en tout cas on a une volonté
extrêmement importante sur ce sujet
monsieur le député villefranc vous
m'avez interrogé sur
sur l'eau et particulièrement sur le
fonctionnement des agences de l'eau et
le financement
il y a un plafond annuel de recette pour
des redevances de l'Agence de l'eau qui
est fixée je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure à 2,2 milliards d'euros depuis
la loi de finances 2021 le projet loi de
finances 2023 et prévoit d'ailleurs
comme 2022 le maintien du plafond
d'emploi des agences de l'eau et ce qui
montre la reconnaissance de l'État
vis-à-vis de ces opérateurs même si on
aimerait que tous les postes les ETP
augmente c'est aussi un signe qu'on
souhaite privilégier compte tenu qu'il y
a d'autres postes de dépenses qui qui
sont amenés à abaisser et pour
contribuer à répondre à l'adaptation au
changement climatique les agences de
l'eau ont pu déployer grâce à un
relèvement de leur plafond de dépenses
dès l'été 2022 un plein de résilience
d'un montant de 100 millions d'euros
pour
pouvoir soutenir les collectivités en
matière d'économie d'eau mais aussi pour
lutter contre les Pyrénées pénuries
qu'elles ont pu connaître parce que
c'est vrai que la sécheresse on l'a vécu
des dès le printemps accompagner les
filières agricoles mais également aussi
améliorer la rés des territoires et des
milieux naturels et cette opération elle
est efficace pour des projets et l'idée
c'est d'éviter évidemment que ça
s'appuie se reproduire
ensuite et pour la dernière question je
crois avoir été assez complète
vous m'avez interrogé sur la consigne
donc je vous ai précisé d'ailleurs que
c'était un sujet qui allait revenir en
fait je suis empêché par la loi qui a
été votée il y a quelques temps qui en
fait étonnamment donne une date pour
reprendre le
négociations c'est à dire je n'ai pas
l'opportunité d'engager les discussions
sur sur la consigne avant c'est juin
2023 donc en attendant juin 2023 c'est
ce que dit la loi la loi
voilà c'est ce qui avait été
indiqué lorsqu'il y avait eu des bas
notamment avec les sénateurs qui
mettaient un point d'honneur à ne pas
aborder ce sujet de la consigne donc
voilà aujourd'hui la consigne avance et
je crois que le les échanges qu'il y a
eu sur la consigne la loi Jacques n'ont
pas été
réalisés pour rien pourquoi je dis ça
c'est parce qu'en fait ça a commencé
évidemment
ça a permis d'avancer sur le sur le
sujet et ce qui avait été indiqué au
sénateur et aux élus les collectivités à
ce moment là c'était de dire en gros
c'est regrettable que vous n'abordez pas
cette question parce qu'en fait on y
reviendra
déjà pour évidemment réaliser les
objectifs de mieux récupérer le
plastique parce que on voit bien que
dans les pays qui sont des pays
limitrophes notamment l'Allemagne elle
recycle mieux parce qu'en fait elle a
mis en place la consigne et qui a pas de
secret c'est comme ça que ça on va mieux
récupérer le plastique mais c'est aussi
que en fait depuis
2019-2020 oui c'est ça il y a en fait la
mise en place de de consignes sauvage
et en fait les collectivités perdent du
coup de la des quantités plastiques et
donc bah perdre aussi de l'argent donc
beaucoup de collectivités commencent à
s'interroger sur le fait de dire bah à
défaut on n'en voulait pas mais va
peut-être falloir qu'on y réfléchisse
parce qu'en fait sinon les la consigne
va se faire de façon sauvage et donc on
va perdre de l'argent sur les derniers
chiffres que j'avais le plastique
c'était 700 euros la tonne donc vous
imaginez que ça peut représenter un
certain montant pour les collectivités
donc je pense qu'on est aujourd'hui en
tout cas dans une temporalité voilà
d'ici d'ici à l'année prochaine d'ici en
juin 2023 je pense qu'on pourra engager
la discussion extrêmement sérieusement
en tout cas moi j'attends pas lorsque je
vois des sénateurs pour leur en parler
j'attends pas juin 2023 pour aborder la
question
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
merci madame la ministre d'avoir répondu
très bien vous êtes inscrite parfait
alors attendez oui
je vous propose de lancer une certaine
de questions parce que ce sont inscrits
je laisse
la parole à Sophie pas de nacle
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre les besoins en eau en
considérablement augmenté tant dans
l'agriculture que dans l'industrie il en
est de même chez les particuliers toutes
les études annoncent une progression de
la demande de 10 à 12% dans les 20
prochaines années la réponse dans
l'urgence aux canicules consiste
effectivement à enclencher comme cet été
le principe de restriction dans le but
d'éviter la pénurie d'eau mais n'est-il
pas mieux de répondre par anticipation
aux problèmes de la gestion de la
ressource en eau potable dans cet esprit
la loi économie circulaire du 10 février
2020 inscrit plusieurs dispositions
visant à encourager la réutilisation des
zones non conventionnelles l'article 70
de la loi prévoit pour les constructions
nouvelles qu'un décret détermine à
partir de 2023 les exigences de
limitation de consommation d'eau potable
dans le respect des contraintes
sanitaires notamment s'agissant des
dispositifs de récupération des eaux de
pluie je remercie maintenant que Madame
la Ministre pardon de nous en dire plus
sur le contenu de ce décret qui n'attend
plus que votre signature et je vous
attends avec plaisir sur la commune de
Mios pour rencontrer l'entreprise quipo
pluie de récupération d'eau de pluie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Jean-François l'ovizolo
merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre ma question porte sur
les préoccupations des producteurs
agricoles de cerise de raisin
relative à l'obligation prévue par la
loi GEC interdisant juillet 2023 pour le
raisin et en janvier 2025 pour la cerise
le conditionnement barquette plastique
si la volonté législateur de réduire
drastiquement le recours aux emballage
plastique et plus que louable il est
indispensable que sa mise en oeuvre
puisse prendre en compte certaines
spécificités en pratique les cerises ou
l'oreille ou le raisin sont cueillis à
maturité et sont particulièrement
fragiles il supporte très mal la
manipulation liée à la vente en break
techniquement des essais réalisés pour
remplacer la barquette plastique par en
contenant en carton mais ces derniers
sont peu probants en effet lorsque
l'humidité du fruit en tant que tête
avec le carton sont pourrissement est
accéléré connaissance de réalité mais
aussi les enjeux d'économie circulaire
qui sont indispensables pour lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique à titre
d'exemple là open muscade de Provence a
opté pour une nouvelle barquettes 85%
recyclées et 100% recyclable
actuellement aucun conditionnement haut
alternative ne semble satisfaisant pour
les fruits fragiles il semblerait
intéressant de les circuiter à la
recherche pour trouver des solutions
interactives totalement opérationnelles
merci président merci la parole est à
Philippe guillemin
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre ma question porte également sur
l'eau madame la ministre vous avez déjà
répondu par anticipation à de nombreux
points ma collègue également à poser une
question à ce sujet
ce budget tient compte des enjeux de la
préservation de la biodiversité vous
l'avez rappelé également deux éléments
répondre à l'urgence avez-vous dit et
planifier nos usages simplement vous
pouvez vous revenir sur les moyens
envisagés les différents leviers pour
atteindre une baisse de prélèvement de
10% en 2025 et 25% d'ici 2035 objectifs
qui constitue votre feuille de route
merci cher collègue la parole est à Emma
Caron
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre le week-end dernier encore
quatre promeneurs ont été blessés par
des chasseurs dont un grièvement c'est
très habituel et c'est très gênant parce
que toutes les Françaises et tous les
Français devraient avoir le droit de
profiter de la biodiversité sans risquer
de se faire tirer dessus mais vous les
chasseurs vous les aimez bien au point
que vous autorisez des chaises
traditionnels interdites par l'Europe et
ce alors qu'on chasse déjà chez nous
deux à trois deux à trois fois plus
d'espèces que chez nos voisins vous
aimez les chasseurs au point qu'il
bénéficient aujourd'hui de subventions
publiques pharaonique
officiellement destiné notamment à des
missions de préservation de la
biodiversité des écosystèmes pourtant
les associations et l'Office français de
la biodiversité doutent du bon usage de
ces fonds et moi aussi madame la
ministre ma question comment pouvez-vous
confier en partie en tout cas la
protection de la biodiversité a des
hommes et à des femmes parce qu'il y en
a aussi dont le plaisir est de tuer des
représentants de cette biodiversité
comme la reconnue lui-même le président
des chasseurs en déclarant sur une radio
je cite moi j'en ai rien à [__] de
réguler mon plaisir c'est la chasse
si et enfin la parole est à Jean-Louis
Brico
[Musique]
et qu'on est hors de vente éducatif on
se débarrasse pas parce que de toute
façon ça change ça change pas la facture
et dans les collectifs on voit même
c'est ces familles qui mettent dans le
déchet des cartons plus des déchets
ultimes et avec tous les problèmes que
ça vous propose alors qu'est-ce que vous
comment vous voyez un petit peu la
gestion collective dans les appartements
collectifs et puis ce qui faut pas une
dimension sociale dans cette redevance
incitative merci chers collègues
madame la ministre je vous laisse le
soin de répondre
je suis d'accord
c'est bon c'est bon
alors
madame la députée panonacle alors vous
le soulignez nous devons baisser notre
notre consommation d'eau et les efforts
doivent porter sur tous les secteurs
fuites de canalisation production
agricole industrie récupération des eaux
de pluie et comme vous l'évoquez dans
les constructions neuves c'est le but de
l'article 70 de la loi ajec que vous
avez cité les déclinaisons
réglementaires de cette disposition
nécessite des travaux préparatoires
actuellement en cours il faut trouver
l'équilibre entre sobriété pour l'usage
de l'eau potable et coût de la
construction du secteur logement la
concertation des acteurs va
prochainement démarrer pour une
publication et une mise en application
en 2023 de ces nouvelles obligations en
termes de limitation de la consommation
d'eau potable pour les constructions
nouvelles et le Centre Scientifique et
Technique du Bâtiment et le cerema
travaille actuellement à l'élaboration
d'une proposition de mode de calcul donc
un nouvel méthode de réglementaires de
ces nouvelles normes elle sera
développée sur le périmètre de la
réglementation dite re 2020 qui est
notre standard pour la performance
environnementale des bâtiments celle-ci
contient déjà dans sa méthode d'analyse
de cycle de vie un calcul des
consommations d'eau potable un calcul
des apports en eau de pluie et prend
déjà en compte quelques systèmes
hydroéconomes ce calcul sera donc devra
sera donc amélioré par la mise en oeuvre
d'autres solutions telles que la
robinetterie hydroéconome et l'usage des
eaux grises et de manière plus globale
le ministère travaille actuellement à
l'élaboration d'un plan visant à mieux
cerner les possibilités de réutilisation
de pluie dans les bâtiments et leur
espace vert à identifier les freins à
leur déploiement et à lever dans la
mesure du possible évidemment ces
contraintes les résultats de ces travaux
sont prévus pour la fin d'année 2022 et
seront concertés avec le secteur du
bâtiment en 2023 donc vous voyez c'est
ici à quelques mois
monsieur le député l'ovisolo
alors vous m'avez
interrogé notamment sur le sujet de
l'emballage des fruits et légumes et
donc la loi anti-gaspillage a prévu
justement la fin du suremballage
plastique des fruits et légumes à
compter du 1er janvier 2022 et elle a
tout de même prévu des dérogations pour
les fruits et légumes fragiles qui
présentent un risque de détérioration
lors de leur vente en vrac
l'identification par décret de ces
fruits et légumes fragiles a été faites
en concertation avec le monde agricole
et repose sur les travaux du Conseil
national de l'alimentation c'est qu'on
s'est conformément aux recommandations
de ce conseil national de l'alimentation
que le décret prévoit une sortie
progressive jusqu'en 2026 des emballages
plastiques pour les fruits et légumes
les plus fragiles plutôt que d'accorder
en fait des des dérogations qui
videraient la mesure de sa substance
l'État souhaite accompagner la
substitution de ses emballages
plastiques donc il y a 40 millions
d'euros qui ont été ainsi fléchés pour
le soutien au réemploi et aux activités
de réduction ou de substitution des
emballages plastiques dans le cadre du
plan de relance sur 2021 2022 ça donne
un avantage compétitif aux entreprises
françaises c'est aussi évidemment
important à prendre en compte et il
s'agit d'encourager aussi de nouvelles
modèles de consommation plus respectueux
de l'environnement avec des alternatives
au plastique à usage unique et le
développement de la vente en vrac donc
le gouvernement suit évidemment
attentivement l'évolution des
différentes filières fruits et légumes
en lien avec l'interprofession donc les
échanges sont en cours et nous resterons
évidemment pragmatiques dans le cas où
certaines filières auront besoin de
quelques semaines supplémentaires pour
finaliser leurs travaux de mise en
conformité ou même de gérer des stocks
des surplus de stock mais l'idée
vraiment c'est pas de revenir sur
l'ambition qui a été votée par le
Parlement je pense que voilà l'histoire
nous amène pas à aller dans ce sens
j'en viens à la
question desmeric Caron même si en fait
monsieur le député vous n'aviez pas de
question vous aviez des accusations et
moi j'ai envie de vous répondre
sur votre premier propos parce que c'est
un sujet qui me préoccupe c'est la
sécurité à la chasse
vous semblez me reprocher d'être d'aimer
ou en tous les cas d'avoir de données
faveur au chasseur je vous rappelle
quand même que je suis en charge des
pratiques siégétiques et j'ai dans mon
portefeuille la chasse je évidemment je
suis amené à rencontrer les
représentants et donc du coup d'avoir
quelques quelques ambitions aussi sur le
sujet je vous rappelle aussi que la
semaine dernière et ça je regrette que
vous n'ayez pas mentionné mais nous
avons ça a été non non mais je mais oui
mais vous avez souligné les mauvais
points et vous avez pas forcément
souligné les bons donc je me permets de
le faire dans ma réponse
mais on a et d'ailleurs ça a été c'est
une initiative parlementaire que je
souhaite saluer et qui a été
particulièrement je crois soutenue par
le gouvernement c'est justement le fait
qu'on ait voté la loi Cardou qui est
devenue la loi Ramos sur la fin de
l'engriègement avec une avancée
complémentaire qui a amené à ce qu'on
baisse qu'on en tous les cas qu'on fasse
tomber les grillages après qui ont été
réalisés après 92 alors que la date
initialement amenée dans la loi Cardou
était de 2005 je voulais juste à le
rappeler mais vous avez
vous avez mentionné notamment le sujet
de la pratique de la chasse en effet on
a eu des accidents des accidents
particulièrement
malheureux et qui aurait pu être
beaucoup plus grave que ce qui ce qu'il
en est donc en effet moi aussi ça me
préoccupe vous savez il y a un rapport
qui est sorti du Sénat moi je souhaite
vraiment saluer la qualité parce qu'il y
a une trentaine de propositions avec des
propositions qui sont fortes et qui
n'ont pas forcément été bien accueillis
par la Fédération nationale de la chasse
moi je pense pas que en tous les cas
cette ce rapport il soit en dessous de
l'ambition que nous portons en termes de
de matière de sécurité de la chasse et
je crois qu'il faut qu'on regarde avec
attention les propositions qui sont qui
sont faites
c'est un sujet qui est complexe avec un
double enjeu il y a la protection
évidemment des promeneurs et des
riverains d'un côté et la protection des
chasseurs eux-mêmes parce qu'on voit
bien qu'il y a de nombreux et c'est en
grande majorité des chasseurs qui tirent
sur d'autres chasseurs donc il faut
aussi qu'on puisse protéger ceux qui
réalisent des enfin qui qui ont ce
loisir et au-delà de protection c'est
aussi le sentiment de sécurité qu'il
nous faut parfois retrouver et donc le
rapport des sénateurs aborde les deux
aspects du problème avec des
propositions qui tiennent de la
prévention des accidents et d'autres de
la bonne information du public et l'un
ne va pas sans l'autre et désormais doit
s'engager un travail de concertation à
la fois entre les ministères concernés
notamment ceux la transition écologique
et de l'intérieur
par exemple sur la question des armes
avec les parlementaires et les
différents acteurs je pense aux chasseur
mais aussi aux associations
environnementales ou de sport et nature
et également les élus locaux il y a en
effet dans ce rapport des mesures qui
tiennent de la loi du règlement mais
aussi des outils de planification locale
donc il faut qu'on regarde tout ça et ce
qu'on peut d'ores et déjà souligner
avant même d'entamer cette nouvelle
phase de concertation et que certaines
mesures proposées sont particulièrement
fortes je vous le disais et donc je
pense qu'il faut qu'on trouve très
rapidement des des pistes d'amélioration
moi j'ai d'ores et déjà prévu
d'accompagner
l'Office français de la biodiversité sur
une action de contrôle chasse d'ici à
une quinzaine de jours sur les vacances
de la Toussaint pour aller voir comment
sont pratiquaient les contrôles de la
chasse et je rencontrerai les les
parties prenantes je vous le disais
également la Fédération nationale de la
chasse pour voir comment on peut avancer
sur certaines propositions je pense
évidemment aux propositions qui sont
issues du rapport des sénateurs mais
évidemment aussi à toutes les bonnes
mesures qui peuvent venir d'ailleurs
donc n'hésitez pas à faire des
propositions mais ce député Caron je
suis évidemment
attentive l'idée n'étant pas évidemment
et là vous n'aurez pas en soutien de
totalement éliminer la chasse en France
non mais il faudra la chasse de
régulation donc je ne pense pas que ça
viendra
sinon et vous avez aussi porté le sujet
de je voulais vous répondre sur les
co-constructions aujourd'hui tout est
contrôlé
avant tout est contrôlé pour la mise en
oeuvre par le CA de l'ofb donc il y a
pas de d'abus sur sur l'éco-construction
monsieur le député Guimard je vous ai
perdu de monsieur je vous avais perdu de
vue
vous avez parlé d'économie sur le sujet
de l'économie de l'eau
donc déjà la première le premier
objectif c'est de réduire les fuites
dans les réseaux en effet en fait on a
une grande disparité sur le territoire
on a environ un peu plus de 20% de notre
eau produite qui n'arrive pas au robinet
et on a des grandes disparités on a
évidemment à peine 5% dans certains
territoires plutôt des territoires
citadins et on se retrouve avec plus de
70% de perte en eau dans des territoires
plutôt ruraux ou montagneux
je tiens quand même aussi à souligner
que il y a des collectivités qui ont
fait des investissements depuis
longtemps et je tiens vraiment à saluer
leur l'ambition qu'ils ont eu très tôt
parce qu'en fait ils ont accepté d'Aug
monter un petit peu le prix de l'eau
pour pouvoir faire ces
investissements et c'est important de le
souligner parce que c'est vrai que ce
sont des investissements que souvent les
élus locaux roching à réaliser pourquoi
parce qu'en fait ça ne se voit pas
et ça coûte cher ça ne se voit pas et en
général quand les travaux sont en train
d'être effectués ça gêne plutôt la
population donc ils sont plutôt à
remettre à l'année suivante et voir au
mandat suivant pour réaliser les travaux
nécessaires donc évidemment c'est
indispensable on doit accompagner les
collectivités à le faire surtout les
plus petites collectivités je crois pas
forcément très bon vu qu'il y avait une
proposition de loi au Sénat notamment
pour redonner la gestion de l'eau aux
communes en tous les cas de pas
favoriser les
l'Inter
oui voilà et là je le regrette parce que
je pense pas que ça aille dans justement
dans le bon sens compte tenu qu'elles
ont besoin d'ingénierie et qu'elles
n'ont pas forcément intérêt à gérer seul
lot de leur commune enfin je crois que
c'est pas c'est c'est pas bon compte
tenu des résultats que nous avons
améliorer les logements évidemment il
faut
utiliser
l'eau qui arrive directement évidemment
de la pluie qui revient des toitures et
user l'eau de la des douches dans les
toilettes c'est des choses qui peuvent
être imaginées il y a des il y en a qui
le font et c'est pas assez généralisé
donc c'est des choses qu'il faut
évidemment regarder réutiliser les eaux
usées traitées je les dis tout à l'heure
mais c'est évidemment aussi un objectif
pour pouvoir notamment
arroser des espaces publics je pense que
c'est nécessaire
et donc il y a évidemment plusieurs
objectifs il y a évidemment traiter le
sujet tout à l'heure je l'ai dit
l'agriculture il y a également le sujet
de l'industrie l'un ne va pas sans
l'autre et que la charge elle l'a pas à
pesée que sur les ménages évidemment
l'agriculture c'est une évolution des
cultures avec l'amélioration aussi des
systèmes des systèmes d'irrigation
les l'industrie il faut aussi améliorer
les techniques donc voilà dans le cadre
du chantier qui a été lancé avec le
ministre Christophe Béchu on va vraiment
engager une vraie planification et qui
va vers la sobriété et pour atteindre
aussi les objectifs qu'on s'est fixés
notamment dans le varen de l'eau
monsieur Brico sur les dépôts sauvages
et la tarification donc moi je suis
plutôt favorable à une approche plus
sociale de la tarification incitative
la tarification incitative c'est un
outil qui est utile et qui marche pour
inciter tout le monde à réduire les
déchets à mieux les trier mais aussi à
mieux les recycler mais c'est un outil
qui peut être complexe aussi à déployer
pour les collectivités
une approche sociale de cette
tarification incitative sera plus
complexe encore mais je suis favorable à
ce que l'on puisse y travailler pour
voir comment déployer cette tarification
incitative et la rendre plus sociale
donc voilà je suis je suis évidemment
attentif au sujet mais c'est pas si
simple en tous les cas à déployer sur
les collectivités
oui j'avais pas répondu monsieur
sainte-huile qui m'a fait la remarque
même si j'avais déjà abordé la TGAP
notamment avec le monsieur le député
vous m'avez interrogé notamment sur
le budget vert qui est présenté donc
hors impact de la hausse des prix de
l'énergie et en effet en fait on ne
prend on indique une trajectoire
structurelle qu'il faut prendre en
compte et non pas conjoncturel et donc
on ne regarde pas la situation atypique
que nous sommes en train de vivre
c'était la seule petite indication que
je vous avais pas donné mais sur la TGAP
c'est bien d'inciter pour pour ne pas
mettre en décharge donc c'est ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure à Monsieur
delautraite
chers collègues vous avez la possibilité
de répondre à propos de la ministre et
vous les réponses
d'abord mon apostrophe par le pronom
personnel vous ne vous visez pas
personnellement j'espère que vous l'avez
bien compris mais visez beaucoup
maintenant on se connaît pas encore
beaucoup et vous êtes encore assez
récente à ce poste non je visais bien
évidemment à travers vous mais je vous
permets de m'excuser le président
lui-même qui depuis qu'il est arrivé il
y a donc plus de 5 ans n'a cessé de
multiplier les cadeaux aux chasseurs à
commencer par la division du prix du
permis de chasse par deux ou encore
récemment voilà la possibilité de
chasser des espèces que nous interdit de
chasser l'Europe on l'a encore vu avec
Alouette Deschamps alors que Monsieur
Béchu m'avait lui-même affirmé les yeux
dans les yeux dans l'hémicycle il y a
trois semaines qu'il attendait le
Conseil d'État avant de prendre une
décision à ce sujet donc ce sont bien
ces cadeaux que je dénonce il y avait
pourtant une question même si vous dites
que ce n'était qu'une critique non
c'était une question critique
et ma question évidemment elle
concernait l'usage de cette écho
contribution vous m'avez répondu que
finalement tout allait pour le mieux
dans le meilleur des mondes puis c'est
ce que disait le FB dit exactement
l'inverse de ce que vous prétendez
le 18 novembre 2021 avis du conseil
scientifique de l'EFD le Conseil
Scientifique fait le constat que le
dispositif de l'écho contribution mis en
place ne permet pas de garantir une
qualité suffisante des projets
sélectionnés il y a un manque
d'information présent dans les dossiers
il est impossible de procéder à une
réelle sélection et de refuser des
dossiers induits par le faible nombre de
dossiers proposés etc etc etc j'ai peu
de temps donc je ne peux pas développer
davantage mais contrairement à ce que
vous allez affirmé l'ofb montre
justement que ce dispositif aujourd'hui
ne fonctionne pas et je serai curieux de
savoir ce que le gouvernement a prévu
pour contrer cette critique très forte
merci et enfin Monsieur saint tuile pour
répondre
je reprends la parole 20 secondes sur la
TGAP parce que le coller de l'autre aide
est évoqué la ventilation de la TGAP la
question que je vous posais qui n'est
pas une question simple j'en conviens de
votre ministère c'est l'augmentation de
la TGAP est une bonne nouvelle pour nos
finances et une trajectoire que nous
connaissons mais cela impacte les
collectivités particulièrement les EPCI
qui font face à des augmentations de
dépenses qui s'additionnent aux
augmentations énergétiques la question
que je vous posais c'est comment vous
dialoguer avec les EPCI pour faire en
sorte de rendre les choses acceptables
et de leur donner des éléments et des
outils qui leur permettent de mettre en
oeuvre des pratiques vertueuses dans un
délai qui n'est pas aussi rapide qu'on
le mettrait et qui nous permettrait
néanmoins d'atteindre à terme les
objectifs
merci madame la ministre
alors
[Musique]
répondre à Monsieur Caron
j'ai été interpellé tout à l'heure sur
la chasse à l'alouette alors l'Europe
n'interdit pas la chasse à l'alouette
mais en effet interdit et enfin encadre
les chasses traditionnelles je ne vous
je ne vous contredis pas sur sur ce que
vous venez de d'évoquer
sinon vous avez parlé d'écocontributions
alors en effet vous avez raison l'ofb
avait donné une certaine liste de
failles justement sur les projets et on
a un nouveau cadre qui a été fixé
justement pour que ce soit mieux bordé
et donc que le l'ofb est davantage
justement d'éléments pour pouvoir rendre
des décisions mieux éclairées pour
justement accepter les projets qui sont
financés par les co-constructions
la TGAP donc
l'augmentation clairement ça impacte les
collectivités
comment on dialogue alors avec tous les
outils qui viennent orienter les projets
vers les vers les plus de vertus
clairement on a on a lancé les
concertations on
dialogue régulièrement avec les EPCI
après vous dire qu'il y a un cadre qui
est engagé pas encore c'est à dire que
on a des échanges avec les EPCI mais on
n'a pas si vous voulez de ligne de fin
de concertation organisée aujourd'hui
avec un retour à telle date etc ça n'a
pas été engagé
nous continuons les questions Stéphane
Bichou
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je vais vous parler érosion
côtière et érosion des plages et recule
du trait de côte le 28 septembre dernier
l'Institut National de la Formation
géographique a lancé une nouvelle alerte
pardon sur l'érosion des plages et le
recul du trait de côte en août en août
dernier la loi climat et résilience a
été des avancées majeures en particulier
sur la question de l'information
mais comme vous le savez un point noir
demeure c'est le financement de ce sujet
le financement de cette adaptation et je
sais votre engagement a enfin aboutir
vous avez annoncé il y a quelques jours
lorsque nous étions ensemble au
Grau-du-Roi où j'en ai nationale de
Lanelle une concertation et je sais
vraiment votre votre engagement à à
régler ce sujet très important comme
vous le savez les attentes sont
extrêmement fortes et c'est pourquoi je
souhaite connaître le calendrier que que
vous vous êtes fixé la mise en œuvre
concrète de ce qui va se passer et
surtout surtout que vous puissiez nous
garantir qu'à l'issue de cette
concertation de réelles solutions
financières pérenne seront apportées je
vous remercie un collègue la parole est
à Damien Adam
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre remercier d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous interroger
au titre de notre rôle de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement pour aborder
avec vous deux sujets et de mesures de
la loi agéique anti-gaspillage et
économie circulaire où en est-on du
déploiement des fontaines à eau dans les
établissements recevant du public qui
est obligatoire depuis le 1er janvier
2022 à partir de 300 personnes
accueillies des contrôles ont-ils été
effectué ne serait-il pas tant également
de réfléchir à un élargissement de la
mesure également à propos de
l'interdiction de la vaisselle jetable
dans la région la restauration
collective qui est prévue au 1er janvier
2023 combien d'établissements sont-ils
déjà aujourd'hui à jour de cette
réglementation pensez-vous que les
acteurs seront prêts à la date du 1er
janvier 2023 et des sanctions sont-elles
prévues en cas de manquement et quel
contrôle prévoyez-vous de mettre en
œuvre des janvier prochain pour
s'assurer de la mise en oeuvre de cette
mesure effective je vous remercie merci
la parole tu as Emmanuel Mandon
oui merci président madame la ministre
permettez-moi dans le prolongement de la
démarche initiée par le président de la
Fédération des Parcs naturels régionaux
de France vous alerter à mon tour sur le
lourd contrecoup pour les finances des
syndicats mixtes des parcs la hausse du
point d'indice des fonctionnaires avec
plus de 2200 agents répartis sur 58
parcs c'est un impact budgétaire annuel
de 5 millions d'euros pour ces
structures qui ont des budgets de
fonctionnement largement dominés par les
dépenses de personnel environ 72% en
moyenne on nous le savons ce qui fait la
force des PNR depuis 1967 c'est bien
leur agilité leur capacité à innover
à expérimenter dans le champ de la
transition écologique et du
développement durable grâce à une
capacité d'ingénierie très intéressante
alors à l'heure de l'examen de ce budget
de votre budget il conviendrait sans
doute que les PNL ne soient pas oubliés
donc je vous en remercie par avance
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Lisa bellu
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre pour votre réponse j'ai
à ma question précédente j'ai une autre
question sur l'eau mais cette fois
plutôt sur la qualité de l'eau
en fait je suis tombée aujourd'hui sur
un article qui fait suite à une
une révélation on va dire de
l'association Générations Futures enfin
c'est peut-être pas le bon terme vous
inquiétez pas mais l'association
génération future dénonce le relèvement
des seuils de tolérance de deux
métabolites de l'herbicide s métaux
métaux la chlor et les métabolites c'est
des molécules dégradées en fait dans
l'eau de boisson et c'est métabolites
étaient considérés comme pertinents
c'est à dire potentiellement dangereux
depuis un rapport de lancest de février
2021 et puis le viennent d'être classé
en non pertinent et du coup le seuil
dans l'eau de boisson est pas est passé
de 0,1 microgramme par litre à 0,9
microgrammes par litre donc est-ce que
vous pourriez nous indiquer ce qu'il
présider à cette décision et puis
éventuellement avez-vous des éléments à
nous communiquer pour nous rassurer sur
le fait que ce relèvement de seuil n'est
pas dangereux pour la santé humaine s'il
vous plaît
la parole est à Marcelin ado
la première ayant très le collègue de
vend des lèvres ok au trait de côté la
seconde et un trait à la question des
forêts et de l'ONF en particulier
notamment aux Antilles alors sur le
premier point et effectivement je pense
que la question du trait de côte lié
d'ailleurs la submersion marine connaît
l'acuité particulière s'agissant de
territoire fortement exposés au risque
cycloniques ce qui a démontré d'ailleurs
le passage du dernier cyclone en
Guadeloupe donc effectivement nous
savons qu'à travers la loi climat
résilience il y a des possibilités et
que beaucoup de territoires j'en connais
un ce sont résolument engagés dans un
projet de recomposition spatiale mais
quid du financement justement de ces
projets de recomposition spatiale
deuxième question c'est concernant la
forêt et les moyens on connaît la
richesse de nos forêts tropicales en
termes de de hotspot en matière de
biodiversité et il semblerait que en
tout cas en Martinique l'OMF n'est pas
toujours les moyens de remplir ses
missions avec connaissant
des problèmes financiers graves de
graves déficit et est obligé très
souvent pour remplir ces missions
fondamentales dans l'intérêt de nos
forêts de faire appel au financement de
nos collectivités locales et
singulièrement la collectivité majeure
qui a collectivité territoriale de
Martinique merci
merci chers collègues la parole est à
David topiac merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je voulais parler de
mon département le GR ce qui est
alimenté par un système nest concernant
l'eau des rivières tout simplement dû au
pied mon Pyréné qui nous coupe les
commandes des eaux des Pyrénées donc
système construit au 19e siècle avec un
canal des lacs d'autres montagnes et des
réserves des lacs de réserve sur le
piémont dans certains sont classés en
zone naturelle de 1000 depuis le 19e
siècle Enfin des lacs du 19e siècle donc
nous allons une problématique de
multi-usage vous le comprenez qui est la
faute pour le potable l'irrigation pour
l'agriculture l'industrie le tourisme
les loisirs la biodiversité
l'énergie aujourd'hui l'eau potable est
payé par les consommateurs l'irrigation
par les agriculteurs l'industrie pays
sono pour les tous les autres usages qui
payent l'eau nous avons une vraie
réflexion à ce moment puisqu'il y a des
investissements sur ce système
artificiel construit par l'homme et puis
aujourd'hui notre réflexion sur le
changement climatique pour nous lancer
les propos que j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure nous sommes sur une agriculture
dans le Gers qui a le maïs un peu de
côté et qui a des difficultés
aujourd'hui le changement climatique
pour des cultures qui sont emblématiques
dans le territoire de l'ail sur des
territoires géocalcaires ou des vignes
sur des sables fauves et nous avons
besoin de renforcer notre système
d'alimentation à nous et notre
irrigation pour faire face au changement
climatique je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Jean Victor castor
donc bonsoir tout le monde madame la
Présidente
ma question elle sera très rapide en
Guyane on n'a pas de problème d'eau nous
avons énormément d'eau sauf que depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années nos fleuves
sont pollués au mercure
et que nous avons des populations
entières qui sont contaminées
toutes les opérations je sais que ça
relève votre ministère mais comme vous
avez la responsabilité de l'eau je suis
obligé de vous interpeller sur le fait
que toutes les opérations militaires qui
sont menées pour combattre leur paillage
clandestin c'est un échec total y
compris les rapports du parc national le
10 qu'est-ce que vous comptez faire
la parole est à Stéphane de l'autre
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre très rapidement je reviens
juste sur une des questions à laquelle
j'ai pas eu de réponse sur la question
de du secteur de la réparation qui
échappe à ma connaissance à la TVA
réduite et j'aurais bien aimé savoir si
tel était le cas et qu'elle serait votre
position quand à cette une évolution
possible merci merci chers collègues on
finit avec les deux prochaines questions
Pascal Boyer
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre d'avoir accepté cette
audition
la montagne est un réservoir d'eau douce
les dans les Hautes-Alpes c'est ce qui
est dit et surtout ce qui est dit dans
la région sud mais avec la fonte des
glaciers la montagne l'aide de moins en
moins la montagne est aussi un réservoir
de biodiversité elle peut devenir de
plus en plus la création de réserves
colinéaire multi-usage par exemple pour
l'agriculture pour les réservoirs d'eau
potable pour l'activité économique de
nos montagnes permet aussi et ce n'est
pas négligeable de et elle permet aussi
ce n'est pas dit que j'ai peut servir
aux habitants des Hautes-Alpes pour la
biodiversité
d'eau douce en plus des services
écosystémiques rendus madame la ministre
prévoyez-vous de dédier une partie de ce
programme pour la création de réserve
colinéaire ce qui serait bien utile dans
les zones de montagne pour alimenter en
eau potable et notamment les communes
qui en
pour alimenter alors pour alimenter les
en eau potable et notamment les communes
qui en sont privées en période de
sécheresse et pour soutenir les
activités anthropiques dans nos
territoires qui sont bénéfiques au
maintien voire au développement de la
biodiversité merci merci chers
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre en parallèle de son
investissement face aux dans la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique le
gouvernement lutte également pour la
préservation de la biodiversité
notamment à travers la stratégie
nationale pour les airs protégées et en
plus de cette stratégie dans le dans
l'accompagnement de cette stratégie la
France prévoit désormais d'accorder de
véritable moyen à la protection de la
biodiversité qui se manifeste aussi par
les millions d'euros issus du fond vert
qui seront amenés à être
distribués consacré de manière locale et
déconcentrée comme on l'a bien compris
parmi ces airs naturelles protégées on
enregistre plus de 350 réserves
naturelles dont 9 dans mon département
en Haute-Savoie et comme vous le savez
les organismes gestionnaires des
réserves naturelles françaises tiennent
d'ailleurs actuellement leur congrès
national pour réfléchir à des
perspectives d'évolution et évoquer des
problématiques qui rencontrent dans un
contexte où certaines collectivités
territoriales hésitent et son confrontés
à des contraintes budgétaires
importantes dans la lutte pour préserver
la biodiversité je voulais donc vous
demander la confirmation de la part du
gouvernement du soutien aux organismes
gestionnaires de ces réserves naturelles
je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame
la ministre
je vous laisse le son de répondre à
toutes ces questions oui elles sont
nombreuses alors je vais essayer de les
prendre dans l'ordre
d'abord sur le sujet du recul du trait
de côte ils sont financement alors vous
l'avez souligné donc vous le savez que
de nouvelles mesures ont été prises dans
le cadre de la loi climat résidence pour
permettre aux communes littoral de
lutter contre l'érosion du trait de côte
dans le cadre de leurs compétences
aménagement et je l'ai dit lors du
congrès de l'Association nationale des
élus du littoral je ne souhaite pas
revenir dessus en revanche j'ai bien
conscience de la nécessité de construire
une capacité pérenne de financement des
adaptations qui seront nécessaires même
indispensables dans les prochaines
années et c'est pour cela que je
souhaite lancer et je l'ai annoncé même
lancer une concertation sur un an qui
doit permettre d'aboutir lors des
prochaines lois de finances sur le fond
nous estimons aujourd'hui à environ 20
millions d'euros le besoin de
financement pour répondre aux enjeux
d'érosion et de submersion et nous avons
conscience que certaines années pourront
nécessiter bien plus et nous devons nous
y préparer à moyen et long terme ce sont
plus de 20 millions d'euros qui seront
engagés sur 2023 dans le cadre du projet
loi de finance le financement de
l'ingénierie et des premières opérations
donc à démarrer l'État a déjà investi 10
millions d'euros du point en France
relance de 2021 à 2023 pour les trois
premiers projets partenariaux
d'aménagement Gouville Lacanau et
Saint-Jean-de-Luz et dès cette année une
enveloppe de 5 millions d'euros par an
et programmé pour accompagner de
nouveaux PPA en faveur de la
recomposition littorale face à l'érosion
côtière et à partir de l'année prochaine
donc en 2023 l'apport supplémentaire de
15 millions d'euros du fond vert
permettra l'engagement rapide de travaux
de cartographie et l'élaboration de
nouveaux PPA il y a aussi l'enveloppe de
4 millions d'euros du plan tourisme
destination France qui a été programmée
sur quatre ans pour accompagner les
diagnostics de camping exposés à
l'érosion marine et enfin l'État s'est
engagé à financer jusqu'à 80% des
cartographies d'évolution du trait de
côte
donc les moyens débloquer ils permettent
de répondre dès à présent aux premières
demandes mais pour l'avenir il est clair
que nous aurons besoin de débattre de la
manière de prévoir des moyens
complémentaires je m'y suis engagée et
j'ai évidemment sollicité votre aide sur
ce sujet monsieur bushoud vous êtes il y
avait aussi monsieur Coste qui
souhaitait être associé je crois à cette
à cette thématique en tout cas cette
question je pense aussi à Madame
panonacle voilà vous êtes très engagé
sur le sujet évidemment tout ce qu'ils
le sont également dans cette salle sont
évidemment les bienvenus l'idée c'est de
lancer cette grande concertation et je
m'engage d'ailleurs à donner cette
feuille de route de la concertation
d'ici à quelques temps là on est en
train de la de la de la finaliser
monsieur Adam vous m'avez questionné
sur le plastique et aussi sur les
fontaines à eau
donc la loi anti-gaspillage elle a prévu
de réduire 50% des plastiques d'ici 2030
donc le nombre de bouteilles puis
précisément
et
l'idée c'est d'éviter évidemment leur
mise sur le marché et pour atteindre cet
objectif la loi elle prévoit notamment
l'obligation pour les établissements
recevant du public de mettre à
disposition de celui-ci des fontaines à
eau librement accessibles alors la mise
en oeuvre de cette de cette
enfin c'est vraiment un challenge faut
le dire de mettre ça en oeuvre dans tous
les établissements qui le requiert
on a plusieurs exemples il y a plus de
150 gares SNCF qui sont concernés par la
mesure donc il s'agit pour la RATP aussi
d'installer plus de 500 fontaines à eau
sur son réseau donc c'est quand même
important et face à ce défi moi il me
paraît souhaitable de nous inscrire en
2022 dans une logique d'accompagnement
de ces acteurs avant d'envisager une
logique répressive la même logique
prévaut pour l'interdiction de la
vaisselle jetable dans la restauration
d'ailleurs sur place prévu par la loi
anti-gaspillage qui s'appliqua à compter
de l'année prochaine même en tout début
d'année prochaine donc certains
établissements sont déjà bien avancés
dans le déploiement de de solutions
réutilisables et d'autres établissements
n'ont même pas encore pris conscience de
cette mesure donc là encore il me semble
pertinent au départ d'accompagner ces
entreprises dans cette transition avant
d'engager une phase répressive
évidemment j'aurais pas le mot même
regard sur des fontaines à eau qui
devront être déployés par la RATP ou
encore par la SNCF qui sont de grosses
entreprises qui ont davantage de moyens
pour mettre en place ces mesures plutôt
que le la petite restauration qui elle
est peut-être un petit peu plus embêtée
dans la mise en place de la fin du
plastique même de surtout quand quand il
s'agit de plastique
pour la restauration sur place parfois
ça peut être même un peu difficile
lorsqu'il s'agit de de certaines de
certaines pratiques et notamment
certaines restaurations je pense
restauration rapide notamment
il y a également une question de
Monsieur Mandon
vous m'avez interpellé sur la situation
de nos 58 parcs voilà 58 parc national
naturel régionaux en France
donc déjà je souhaite commencer ma
réponse en soulignant l'importance de
ces parcs évidemment pour le
développement local la valorisation des
territoires mais aussi la protection de
leur biodiversité sur le fond la
Fédération des PNR m'a saisi de son
inquiétude aussi sur l'augmentation du
point d'indice qui pèse sur le budget
des syndicats mixtes de PNR elle évalue
à 5 millions d'euros le coût de la mise
en oeuvre de cette mesure pour les parcs
et elle évoque des budgets de
fonctionnement en moyenne de 2,9
millions d'euros dont 72% est affecté au
coût de personnel donc c'est en effet
très important les gestionnaires CPN air
sont des syndicats mixtes format doc
spécifique ils sont donc l'émanation des
collectivités territoriales et doivent
bénéficier à ce type de mesures de
protection que nous avons mis en place
l'article 14 de la loi de finances
rectificative de juillet 2022 ainsi
instauré un filet de sécurité auquel les
communes et leurs regroupement peuvent
être éligibles les groupements
correspondent aux établissements publics
de coopération intercommunale et au
syndicat mixtes les syndicats et de
gestion des parcs naturels régionaux qui
comportent des communes parmi leurs
membres sont donc susceptibles d'être
éligibles au filet de sécurité ils
devront pour cela réunir les critères
d'agilité prévus par la loi et chulineux
également que la dotation budgétaire de
soutien aux communes pour la protection
de la biodiversité a été augmentée l'an
dernier pour passer à 24 millions
d'euros au lieu de 10 donc c'est quand
même une belle augmentation ensuite une
nouvelle part au profit des communes se
trouvant dans des parcs naturels
régionaux dotés de 5 millions d'euros
donc l'état attribue une dotation
annuelle de 140 000 euros pour le
soutien à l'ingénierie territoriale des
PNRs existants prioritairement orienté
vers les actions de préservation de la
biodiversité des pays j'essa dotation
n'a pas vocation à couvrir les frais de
fonctionnement
madame la députée belleco en effet moi
j'ai pris connaissance aussi de cette
article j'ai tout de suite interrogé les
services et également lancé sur ce sujet
alors déjà sur les réponses qui m'ont
été données et apportées donc sur les
métabolites de pesticides ce sont
des enjeux en fait sanitaires en cours
d'évaluation de plus en plus précis
c'est une évaluation qui est donnée par
lances donc on peut faire confiance à
l'anxess sur ce sujet ce que je tiens
vraiment à vous préciser c'est que
l'ancien seuil était un seuil de
détection et non pas un seuil sanitaire
donc c'est pour ça que du coup vous avez
pas le même résultat et plus globalement
en fait nous ce qu'on soutient
évidemment au ministère c'est la
prévention
et c'est pour c'est un enjeu c'est un
des enjeux notamment du
de travail qui a été lancé et je disais
notamment avec Agnès firmalobodo sur le
sujet qualité de l'eau et avec Marc féno
parce que c'est bien évidemment le sujet
des produits phytosanitaires qui sont
aussi concernées dans le cadre du CNR
parce qu'on a le sujet de l'eau et des
pratiques agricoles dans le CNR donc on
aura évidemment des avancées extrêmement
importantes à annoncer en début d'année
monsieur tobiac vous m'avez parlé d'un
sujet qui concerne particulièrement
votre circonscription le
[Musique]
le financement du système reste un
dossier qui a été prioritaire par le
bassin à bourg-garonne moi je j'ai
échangé avec eux pas plus tard qu'hier
j'ai
rencontré même si je le connais très
bien monsieur le Président Rousset qui
m'a rappelé évidemment son intérêt sur
le sujet de l'eau et sa préoccupation et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il a mis en
place cette réunion anticipée le partage
du coup évidemment important et je sais
que le préfet conserve les acteurs pour
trouver un équilibre et les conditions
d'un partage donc sur ce sujet vraiment
on aura un certain nombre d'annonces à
faire la gestion de l'eau et j'ai vu que
c'était et je suis heureuse que vous
partagiez ce cette préoccupation avec
moi parce que le sujet de Lolo
évidemment et c'est un sujet extrêmement
important et c'est un sujet qui commence
à prendre aussi auprès des Français mais
de façon peut-être un petit peu moins
importante
je me rends compte une fois sortie des
périodes de sécheresse qu'on nous avons
vécu cet été que
le les Français pensent que la solution
est là et que ces résolu alors que en
fait on sait très bien qu'on va
connaître probablement si on n'a pas
d'avantage de pluie cet automne et cet
hiver a une situation extrêmement
difficile l'année prochaine
sur les retenus colinéaires en zone
montagne madame Boyer
donc vous savez évidemment le changement
climatique a déjà pour conséquence de
modifier le cycle de l'eau on en a
beaucoup parlé aujourd'hui
et répondre à ce défi demande d'avoir
comme objectif une sobriété d'usage de
cette ressource et d'assurer un partage
de l'eau équitable et durable et cela
concerne l'ensemble des usagers et doit
couvrir les besoins prioritaires de la
population la politique de l'eau elle
doit prendre en compte les changements
de long terme elle doit également
favoriser l'émergence de solutions
adaptées au territoire et les retenues
colinaires peuvent être un outil pour
une gestion territorialisée et concertée
de la ressource en eau et de la
protection de la biodiversité
lorsqu'elle s'inscrivent dans les
projets territorialisés de gestion de
l'eau c'est pour ça que je tiens
évidemment au ptge qui sont le socle de
la concertation et la définition des
ouvrages nécessaires pour un territoire
et son gage de l'acceptabilité sociale
des ouvrages je fais également cette
même réponse à la député béluko qui
m'interpellait sur les ptga et notamment
aussi sur des ouvrages sur sur sa
circonscription et à ce titre donc les
ouvrages peuvent être financés par les
agences de l'eau pour les volumes
substituées et en zone montagne mais
comme ailleurs les retenus colinéaires
suivent les mêmes procédures de la
définition du besoin à l'étude d'impact
complète du projet jusqu'à son
autorisation administrative donc
l'analyse doit prendre en compte
évidemment le bon état de la ressource
en nous dans un premier temps et ce
qu'il s'agisse de stockage pour
irrigation ou pour l'élevage ou pour
d'autres usages encore comme
l'alimentation des stations de ski
d'hiver votre question porte enfin sur
l'avenir des moyennes montagnes
françaises et des sports d'hiver alors
que le changement climatique réduit
chaque année les chutes de neige le
gouvernement est très attentif à
construire un avenir durable pour les
activités de montagne et le plan à venir
montagne a consacré 50 millions d'euros
à ces territoires
j'évoquais aussi notamment lorsque
j'étais à Lanelle ce qui a été précisé
par le député du chou tout à l'heure que
le sujet du réchauffement climatique et
de la gestion de l'eau évidemment
globale et que je ne peux pas traiter
uniquement les enfin le sujet du
littoral et la montée des eaux mais
évidemment aussi regarder la sécheresse
dans les milieux ruraux qui va
malheureusement on va connaître des
épisodes de sécheresse beaucoup plus
importantes que les autres années et
également aussi le fait d'avoir des
fonds des neiges et donc des activités
qui vont être aussi modifiées sur ces
territoires montagneux donc tout ça il
va falloir le regarder savoir comment on
finance ce changement d'activité je
crois pas non plus envisageable d'être
jusqu'au-boutiste et d'imaginer
uniquement des retenues colinéaires ou
des bassins des bassines pardon pour
imaginer avoir éternellement si le
réchauffement climatique est important
d'avoir éternellement des activités de
de ce qui si jamais il y avait plus de
neige donc un moment donné il faudra
regarder à l'évolution de l'activité
évidemment de ces territoires pour
pérenniser des activités et faire en
sorte que les personnes qui vivent
puissent continuer à y vivre et de vivre
d'autres activités d'ici là nous verrons
mais en tout cas évidemment on est très
préoccupé sur la situation des
territoires de montagne autant que sur
les autres territoires mais c'est vrai
que le sujet est global et qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à regarder ça évidemment
comme je disais dans sa globalité et
c'est un sujet qui évidemment important
j'ai plusieurs questions notamment sur
l'ONF et notamment
monsieur le député nado que j'ai plaisir
de revoir que nous avons vu notamment à
la nelle justement il y a quelques jours
quelques semaines sur le sujet l'ONF
donc nous augmentons comme j'ai dit dans
mon propos liminaires le financement de
l'ONF au titre de la biodiversité pour
autant comme partout en métropole les
projets relevant de l'accueil du public
sont des projets co-construits et
cofinancés avec les collectivités et
au-delà je signale par par
les questions de de attendez excusez-moi
par exemple que en fait nous aidons
spécifiquement à l'ONF et la
collectivité pour la résorption des
décharges littorales comme en Guadeloupe
à Lens charpentier concernant
[Musique]
l'érosion du trait de côte c'était aussi
votre question je peux pas oublier quoi
que ce soit l'érosion du trait de côte
en Martinique les questions de
l'adaptation
au changement climatique se pose aussi
avec une acuité particulière pour ces
territoires
il y a eu des derniers financements qui
sont d'ores et déjà disponibles pour
couvrir les besoins d'ingénierie et la
réflexion que je conduirai sur l'année à
venir permettra de poser les fondements
d'un mobile de financement robuste
évidemment c'est de regarder dans son
entièreté je le disais à l'instant à la
députée Boyer c'est de regarder
évidemment l'ensemble des territoires et
aussi bien sûr les territoires
ultramarins qui sont particulièrement
concernés par la montée des eaux
il y a également la question sur les
pollutions de l'eau vous avez raison
monsieur castor est particulièrement en
Guyane avec le mercure et la lutte
contre leur paillage illégal qui est une
priorité pour ce territoire et qui doit
aussi être une priorité évidemment pour
pour le gouvernement alors il y a la
réforme du code midi qui encourage une
filière légale encadrée pour évidemment
moins d'impact sur l'environnement et
c'est en cours et en parallèle le
ministère de de l'écologie mais aussi
l'intérieur renforce la lutte contre les
pratiques illégales qui utilisent du
mercure d'ailleurs sur le budget 113 il
est en augmentation et donc on souhaite
évidemment continuer ensemble je sais
que le sujet est complexe et que je vous
apporterai pas la réponse complète ce
soir et vous le savez parce que vous
l'avez vous même précisé mais c'est un
sujet qu'on regarde évidemment avec avec
évidemment beaucoup de beaucoup
d'attention
le monsieur le député dolotrade sur
la TVA réduite ou pas donc vous me
demandez pourquoi le secteur de la
réparation de bénéfices bas de la TVA
réduite donc en fait les effets d'une
TVA réduite sont très incertains en
particulier n'est pas évident que cette
mesure bénéficier aux consommateurs et
augmente la réparation après vous me
demandez pourquoi le la réparation n'est
pas concernée plutôt que les et les
autres leçons donc c'est aussi parce
qu'en fait la
on va dire que la réparation est
financée aussi par les REP
donc en partie il y a déjà une un
accompagnement et donc
l'idée c'est de lancer
en fait des forfaits réparations qui
soient moins cher et ça ce sera d'ici la
fin novembre donc j'aurai l'occasion de
vous redonner des éléments sur le sujet
et enfin j'avais des dernières questions
de la part de du député Armand
d'ailleurs je regrette de pouvoir faire
le déplacement Annecy je tenais à le
repréciser ici parce que je me faisais
un plaisir de venir vous rejoindre
donc demain
donc vous m'avez interrogé sur
nombreuses choses vous avez en tout cas
vous avez souligné plusieurs points le
soutien évidemment est totale au
gestionnaire d'espaces naturels j'ai eu
l'occasion de donner des détails de
financement notamment dans le fond vert
sur les 150 millions dédiés à la
biodiversité il y a notamment 50
millions qui s'est dédiés aux aires
protégées
pour les parcs nationaux c'est 73
millions d'euros qui sont consacrés le
Conservatoire du littoral c'est 28
millions d'euros les PNR également 28
millions d'euros plus la dotation de
biodiversité des communes qui concourent
donc c'est quand même aussi assez
important et les parcs naturels marins
se sont aussi 20 millions d'euros donc
vous voyez on met du budget le fond vert
évidemment il contribue fortement même
si on avait engagé autrement que sur sur
le fond vert déjà des budgets en faveur
de la biodiversité et en soutien des de
l'ensemble des parcs naturels et espace
naturel qui sont évidemment
indispensables pour protéger nos espaces
exceptionnels que nous avons en France
et vous l'avez souligné avec les
nombreux parcs que vous avez déjà sur
votre sur votre territoire
ai-je oublié quelqu'un
je crois pas
tous les collègues ont pu s'exprimer
merci beaucoup madame la ministre merci
d'avoir répondu à toutes les questions
prochaine réunion demain matin à 10h
dans cette même salle pour l'audition de
Madame Caroline cailleux ministre
délégation des collectivités
territoriales sur sa feuille de route et
sur les différents éléments du projet de
loi de finance pour 2023 merci